Moin, Leute.
Excellent.
Boah, ich bin noch viel zu geschwitzt,
um das Headset aufzuziehen.
Was mache ich denn da jetzt?
Ich lege das mal kurz vor mich.
Und ich muss es eh umstöpseln.
Ich muss es eh umstöpseln.
Warte mal kurz.
Sonst hört sich das nämlich wieder so kacke an.
Equate.
Sekunde.
So, jetzt viel besser, ne?
Leute, ich muss
kurz über Kopf abputzen, ey.
Boah, ich bin immer noch
übelst am Schwitzen.
Okay.
Pogu, da bin ich wieder.
Also.
Ich muss gerade meine
zweitägige Rennrunde
absolvieren.
Eigentlich ist es jetzt
sogar nur, war das jetzt ausnahmsweise
mal nur,
den dritten Tag, weil gestern konnte ich nicht.
Dafür bin ich gestern ein bisschen so rumgelaufen.
Insgesamt, glaube ich, fast drei Stunden.
Aber gestern hatte ich
Wartungsarbeiten auf der Arbeit
und musste immer mal wieder an den Rechner.
So.
Hier, Leute, guckt mal. Ich zeige euch mal was.
Twitter.
Ganz, ganz
frisch hier.
Ogge.
Stripes.
Fünf Spillionen Jahre. Danke.
Pog.
Das ist extrem.
Mind blown.
Genau.
Schaut mal kurz hier.
Hä?
Alter, Twitter wird auch immer mehr PP.
Was ist das denn?
Kann man das so anzeigen?
Oder wie geht das jetzt?
Ja.
So kann man das anzeigen.
Guck mal.
Wilder Igel, danke für den Sub.
Splixer. Danke, Leute.
Guck mal hier. Neuer Rekord.
Heute Morgen.
Neuer Rekord.
Bam.
Fünf Kilometer.
Ich war in meiner Strecke, sei nicht 6,2.
Aber ich habe einfach nach fünf gestoppt,
weil ich konnte nicht mehr.
Das war genug für mich.
Fünf Kilometer.
Fünf Minuten 45 pro Kilometer.
Also ich hatte,
laut meiner Watch,
waren das eigentlich
drei Rekorde auf der Strecke.
Nämlich
ein Kilometer,
neue Bestzeit,
fünf Minuten 33,
neun Minuten sieben
für eine Meile
und 28,51 für fünf Kilometer.
Also so wie das teilweise umschrieben wird, nicht.
Also ich meine,
das längste, was ich gerannt bin,
bisher waren glaube ich 8,2 oder 8,3.
Und das bin ich recht langsam gelaufen.
Dementsprechend war das gar nicht jetzt so,
dass ich mir laufen gedacht habe,
jetzt musst du aber aufhören,
sondern es war eigentlich ganz okay.
Wie lange ich das jetzt mache,
kann ich dir sagen.
Ich muss gucken, wann ich meine Uhr gekauft habe.
Das sage ich euch.
Und nicht so lange.
Ich habe die Hoffnung, dass ich das demnächst auch hinkriege.
Wo habe ich denn meine Uhr gekauft?
So, also die Uhr habe ich am 2. August gekauft.
Und kurz danach habe ich angefangen mit Rennen.
Die habe ich erst mal nur
paar Tage zum Kennenlernen gehabt.
Zum Aufzeichnen und so.
Sagen wir einfach mal,
zwei Wochen nicht an. Sagen wir mal, ich mach
das zwei Monate ungefähr.
Seit Anfang August. Sagen wir mal zwei Monate.
Runden wir ein bisschen auf.
Hä. Ja, sad girl.
Also ungefähr zwei Monate.
Aber man muss dazu sagen,
ich
bin ja vorher schon
jetzt nicht
rennen gegangen, sondern seit
ein paar Jahren laufe ich ja
jeden Tag so, also wirklich laufen, so mit
Stöckchen so, so wie die Rentner so mit Nordic
Walking Stöcke. So eineinhalb,
zwei Stunden. Aber halt
nicht irgendwie super
sportlich oder so.
Dementsprechend
so ein bisschen
Grundkondition und so
hatte ich ja, weil da geht's ja auch Berge hoch.
Aber
also ich muss echt sagen, also
schneller kann ich nicht.
Also ich könnte vielleicht, wenn es wirklich um
Leben und Tod geht, wenn ich wüsste,
okay, ich fall halt,
also ich sterbe sonst sicher,
könnte ich sicherlich noch ein paar Sekunden
schneller, weil ich muss ja
da immer noch so 1,2 Kilometer
heimlaufen danach. Aber
also
also viel schneller. Ich bin, also
hier bin ich, man sieht das ja auch, ja,
165 im Durchschnitt, also
da bin ich auch schon ziemlich im Arsch, ja.
Wusstet ihr, dass das so
ziemlich,
nur dass man das mal
einordnen kann,
der Marathon
Weltrekordhalter,
der hat mal seine Garmin,
äh nicht Garmin, wie heißt das,
Strava-Daten veröffentlicht
und er hat
ich glaube 168
Puls gehabt im Durchschnitt
über einen Marathon.
Also im Prinzip das gleiche wie ich,
nur dass der halt irgendwie 42 Kilometer
rennt und
der ist
ziemlich genau,
ja, ziemlich
genau,
genau, doppelt so schnell,
doppelt so schnell
wie ich
und läuft das 2 Stunden
über 42 Kilometer.
Das ist so krass.
Ich konnte das vorher nie einschätzen,
wie krass das ist, aber
das ist, das ist
echt unmenschlich.
Da muss ich mal
überlegen. Der Typ
läuft
im Durchschnitt
42 Kilometer
schnell,
schneller,
als ich
volle Pulle vielleicht mal
einen Kilometer schaffe.
Das ist echt krass, Alter.
Ja, Ruhepuls wirklich fast nett.
Ich hab mal
vor ein paar Jahren eine Geschichte,
keine Geschichte, also wie nennt man das,
so eine Reportage gelesen,
über einen ehemaligen Tour de France
Profi, der ist gestorben
und
ich glaube wegen Drogenüberdosis,
hatte nichts mit Doping und so zu tun.
Zumindest.
Die haben
über den, also
ein bisschen, haben einen Artikel über
den geschrieben
und der hat erzählt, also Pantani,
genau, ja, das war eines der, also
einer der gedoptesten Ever, aber
was ich halt super krass fand in der
Erzählung, also in dieser Story,
der hat erzählt, in seinen Dopingzeiten
musste, also in seinen Dopingzeiten
hat der irgendwie einen Ruhepuls von 32
oder sowas. Das ist so wirklich, das ist wirklich.
wirklich, der hat gekurzt vor Sark.
So, und da hat er erzählt,
der musste nachts,
nachdem er sich super krass
gedopt hatte,
der hatte ein Pulsfrequenzmesser dran
und wenn
seine Herzfrequenz nachts
irgendwie unter, keine Ahnung,
30 oder so oder 32
gefallen ist, dann musste
er nachts aufstehen und nachts
ein bisschen rennen, weil
sein Blut sonst so dickflüssig
geworden wäre, dass er wahrscheinlich
einen Herzinfarkt oder einen
Schlaganfall oder irgendwas bekommen hätte.
Also seine Ärzte haben zu ihm gesagt,
hier, wenn du,
wenn du, wenn dein Pulswarner
angeht, musst du sofort aufstehen
und dich bewegen. Also er musste mehrfach
nachts raus und sich bewegen, weil sein
Puls zu niedrig war, weil er sonst
durch zu dickflüssiges Blut
irgendwelche Blutgerinnsel bekommen hätte und
Herzinfarkt, dead girl.
Also so krass haben die sich gedopt damals.
Ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen. Die haben eh schon,
da gibt es, da gibt es Berichte
aus der Zeit,
dass das,
dass sie teilweise, wenn du das
Blut
gesehen hast, dass das schon fast dickflüssig
gewesen ist.
So krass voll
gepumpt mit roten Blutkörperchen war das.
Also die Ärzte, die waren
wirklich, die waren wirklich bis
bis unter das Kind zugespritzt
mit irgendwas.
Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Du musst, du wirst gewarnt nachts, dass du
aufstehen musst, dass du keinen Herzinfarkt kriegst.
Nee, du musst dir keine Gedanken
machen. Du musst dir keine Gedanken
machen, weil du hast
ja kein, ähm, kein
Epo oder irgendwelche
anderen Substanzen genommen, dass du
irgendwie, was weiß ich, wie viel mehr
rote Blutkörperchen hast, in
deinem Blut wie
normal.
Wenn du einfach nur trainierst, ist das kein Problem.
Der Typ, der hat einen ultra niedrigen
Ruhepuls, hat aber sich zugespritzt
mit sonst was.
Das ist in Kombination halt das Problem.
Das ist schon heftig, oder?
Ja.
Ja, finde ich auch. Finde ich echt nicht schlecht.
Oh, nee.
Also Yoga habe ich wirklich gar keinen Bock.
Ich habe mir ein Fahrrad gekauft, Leute.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Tom
da ist. Der Tom hat ja gesagt, er kann ja mal
bei sich im Shop gucken.
Aber ich habe mir jetzt woanders ein Fahrrad
gekauft. Aber ich brauche noch ein paar Teile.
Da komme ich vielleicht zu euch.
Ich habe mir ein Fahrrad gekauft. Und zwar
das kommt am Montag an.
Ich habe mir ein...
Einfach, weil das gut lieferbar war.
Ich habe mir
so eins hier gekauft.
Hallo?
In blau.
So eins habe ich
mir gekauft.
War ein Stück
gute Kombination.
Ich will hier auf Wegen fahren. Ich will aber auch
bei uns ein bisschen die... Ich weiß,
die Schweizer lachen sich wieder kaputt.
Die Berge hochfahren.
Und da sind halt viele so auch mal
ein bisschen Matschwaldweg oder
so Kiesel...
Kieselsteinwege und sowas.
Dafür ist das eigentlich echt ganz gut.
Und, was ich auch
ganz gut finde... Also ich wollte unbedingt...
Ich wollte unbedingt eins mit einfacher
Schaltung, nicht mit doppelter.
Ja.
Und das finde ich
eigentlich ganz nice.
Mal gucken.
Montag kommt das an.
Montag kommt das an, oder wenn ich ein bisschen
Fahrrad fahre. Ich brauche noch
einen Helm. Muss ich mal gucken.
Keine
Automatik. Naja.
Elektronische Schaltung aber.
Kein E-Antrieb. Ich will ja
normal fahren.
Ich brauche
erstmal irgendeinen Helm.
Es ist unglaublich, wie viele Leute man auf dem Fahrrad
sieht ohne Helm.
Ja, also das war auch der Grund.
Ich habe nämlich geguckt.
Da habe ich mich auch jeepaden lassen.
Ich habe auch zuerst gedacht, ey, nimmst
ein Fahrrad mit zwei Scheiben.
Ich habe mir jetzt übrigens Fahrrad-Fachsprache
mir angeguckt.
Der vordere, das vordere
Zahnrad hier nennt sich Kettenplatt,
habe ich mir sagen lassen in irgendeinem Fahrradforum.
Und das hintere
nennt sich Kassette.
Und auf der Kassette, diese Ringe
sind Ritzel. Es ist witzig,
wie jedes Gebiet
irgendwelche komischen Fachbegriffe
für irgendwas hat.
Ich habe am Anfang
auch gedacht, ey, nimmst du eins
mit zwei Zahnrädern vorne,
aber
wenn man sich das mal genauer anguckt, ist das
eigentlich, je nachdem was man
machen will, eh relativ
unsinnig, wenn man sich die Übersetzung
anguckt. Also du hast
zum Beispiel,
das gleiche
gibt es nämlich
das gleiche gibt es nämlich auch
mit
zweimal. So,
und jetzt, jetzt kommt der Grund,
warum es eigentlich relativ sinnlos ist,
wenn man, wenn man nicht maximale
Endgeschwindigkeit irgendwie auf der flachen Straße
haben will. Also zumindest
das, wie ich mir das gelesen habe,
ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre das
ultimativ Ratschlag.
Aber guckt mal, hier unten steht bei
Ausstattung, steht, was
man für
Übersetzung hat. Genau, hier guckt mal,
hier gibt es
Moment, das ist das falsche,
oder, was ich aufgemacht habe.
Ach, hier, ne, hier.
Genau, guckt.
Hier gibt es vorne eins mit
48 Zehen und noch
ein kleines mit 31 Zehen
und hinten hat man 11 bis 34.
So, das heißt, wenn man sich jetzt
Gedanken drüber macht, wenn man den Berg hochkommt,
kann man gucken, okay,
was ist die kleinste Übersetzung,
die man fahren kann?
Das ist dann im Endeffekt
ähm,
ist 31 vorne
und
34 hinten.
Das sind dann quasi
31,
31 durch 34.
Ey, what the fuck?
War mal 31,
hab ich richtig geguckt, ja?
31 durch 34, das ist quasi eine Übersetzung,
oder eigentlich ist es, wenn du so willst,
eine Untersetzung, war es schon mit 0,911.
So, und jetzt
kommt das mit 1 mal 11.
1 mal 11 ist vorne.
Zähne und hinten 42.
So, und jetzt pass mal auf.
40, 42,
das sind 0,95.
Das ist jetzt nicht der riesen Unterschied.
Also, wenn du überhaupt nicht
vorwärts kommst auf den Berg,
dann wird es dir das eine zum anderen auch nicht
großartig bringen. Und mit zwei
Blättern vorne
hast du halt
ähm, auch ziemlich
viele Gänge, die halt ähnlich sind.
Wenn du jetzt das kleine nimmst und das mittlere,
ist das wahrscheinlich ähnlich, wie wenn du das große nimmst und irgendwie zwei größer.
Wo das tatsächlich mehr bringt, da wurde ich nämlich auch jeepaded.
Ich dachte, zwei vorne sind sinnvoll, wenn man nicht den Berg richtig hochkommt.
Das stimmt aber überhaupt nicht in dem Fall.
Richtig sinnvoll sind die, wenn du auf der geraden Straße volle Pulle fahren willst,
weil dann kannst du 48,11 fahren und 48,11 ist halt schneller als 40,11.
Also das ist tatsächlich richtig sinnvoll, wenn man geradeaus schnell fahren will.
Weniger, wenn man den Berg hochfahren will.
Und das habe ich auch am Anfang falsch gedacht.
Ich dachte auch, ey, das bringt richtig was.
Es bringt richtig was, wenn man noch einen...
Aber nee, es ist eigentlich eher für massive schnell geradeaus.
Ja, da habe ich das auch eingeben.
Und was viel sinnvoller ist, wenn man tatsächlich nur eine Einfachschaltung hat,
wenn man guckt, ob hier hinten noch ein größeres drauf passt.
Ja, Moment, das kommt drauf an, welche Sachen du montiert hast.
In dem Fall ist das minimal leichter.
Früher hatten die Leute, ich hatte früher mal so einen Mountainbike-Verschnitt.
Da war ich noch deutlich jünger.
Das hatte so drei Blätter vorne bei den Pedalen.
Und die eine war halt wirklich mini.
Und da hattest du bestimmt noch eine krassere Übersetzung.
Aber in dem Fall macht zwei zu eins gar nicht viel aus.
Also ob...
Einmal elf oder einmal elf.
Das macht richtig was aus, eigentlich nur im Flachen, wenn man gerade ausfahren will.
Es gibt teilweise hinten...
Oh, gerade da, da weiß ich...
Es gibt teilweise hinten schon welche.
So Kassetten, die haben bis 51.
Das ist dann noch mal größer.
Einrad-Enjoyer.
Oh ja, mit dem Einrad den Berg hoch, das stelle ich mir auch lustig vor.
Also, das glaube ich nicht.
Das wäre nur ein offizielles...
Da, wie nennt man das?
So ein gesamtes Schalt...
Werkding nimmst, dass der da irgendwie die Kette runterspringt.
Nee.
Das Einzige, worauf du achten musst, zumindest so wie ich das auf Reddit und in Foren gelesen habe,
wenn du vorne zwei Zahnräder hast, dass du bei manchen Kombinationen, je nachdem, also wie schepp die Kette halt ist,
also beispielsweise, wenn du jetzt ganz außen und hinten ganz innen bist, die Kette hat halt ein bisschen mehr Reibung
und du verpulverst ein paar Watt, aber das ist nicht...
Und die Kette geht ein bisschen schneller kaputt, aber das ist jetzt nicht so als explodiert dein Fahrrad.
So, aber jetzt genug hier, Leute.
Was haben wir denn?
Zack, zack, zack.
Zack.
Hier, guck.
Alter Rekord.
Neuer Rekord.
Bock.
Gehen wir mal auf Shithub gucken, was da so trendet.
Und ihr kennt mich ja, AI wird übersprungen.
Oh, nice.
Go dot.
Ich weiß, dass man das nicht...
Ich weiß, dass man das nicht so ausspricht.
Go dot trendet.
Woran das wohl liegt, Leute?
Was der Unity-CEO wohl dazu sagen würde?
Okay, das klingt nach AI.
Hast du schon was zu Mojo gesagt?
Ja, letzte Woche habe ich was dazu gesagt, dass ich es nicht einsehe, irgendeine Sprache mir genauer anzusehen.
Ich meine, es ist ja ein bisschen Python plus extra, aber warum ist das Ganze nicht Open Source?
Heutzutage sind alle nahezu ernstzunehmenden Sprachen und Implementationen,
Implementierung Open Source.
Also warum...
Sogar Java, Alter!
Also sprich...
Warum soll ich irgendeine Closed-Source-Sprache nehmen?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
C-Sharp!
Von einem der ehemaligen Closed-Source und...
Wie hat das Microsoft immer genannt?
Wie hieß diese Strategie von Microsoft früher immer?
Embrace Extingu...
Nee.
Embrace Extend Extinguish.
Wo sie irgendwelche Technologien genommen haben, die es schon gab, mit irgendwelchem inkompatiblen Shit von ihnen erweitert haben,
sodass das andere ausgelöscht wurde.
Ja, also mit einem der in der Vergangenheit zumindest nervigsten Unternehmenspraktiken, Läden überhaupt.
Sogar Microsoft hat das .NET Framework, beziehungsweise eigentlich...
Ja doch, mittlerweile darf man das ja wieder .NET nennen, nicht .NET Framework.
Ist sogar .NET Open Source.
Was macht das für einen Unterschied?
Ob das Open Source ist?
Naja, dass du zum Beispiel nachgucken kannst, dass keine Malware drin ist.
Ich meine, ich gehe jetzt mal nicht von aus, dass es ist, aber...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine...
Da kann prinzipiell alles drin sein.
Das ist so das Erste, was mir einfällt.
Oder dass wenn du...
Irgendwas hast, was sich ganz furchtbar komisch verhält.
Ja.
Stell dir vor...
Stell dir vor, du hast eine Liste.
So.
Du hast ein Array.
1, 2, 3.
Du sagst Sort.
Und das braucht eine Millisekunde zum Sortieren.
Wobei, das ist schon sortiert.
3, 2, 5.
So.
Sort.
Brauchst eine Millisekunde.
Das ist übrigens enorm, enorm langsam.
Eine Millisekunde an der Stelle nochmal angemerkt, ja.
Als wenn das wirklich eine Millisekunde brauchen würde, dann müsste ich eine Runde kecken.
Aber...
So.
Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du sagst dann 1, 2, 3...
Du machst jetzt Sort.
Und es dauert 100 Millisekunden.
100 Millisekunden.
Was machst du dann?
Dann denkst du jetzt, okay, hm.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, warum das so ist.
Aber ich kann mir die Implementierung von denen ihrer Sortfunktion gar nicht angucken.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Also hauptsächlich würde ich mir tatsächlich Gedanken drum machen.
Ich weiß nicht, was letztendlich am Ende in meinem Programm landet.
Beziehungsweise nicht nur unbedingt in den Programmen landet.
Das kann man ja zur Not noch irgendwie durch genug Analyse rauskriegen.
Sondern auch, was die ganzen Entwicklungen...
Die ganzen Entwicklertools machen.
Was macht der Compiler?
Was landet bei mir auf dem Rechner?
Generell, ich finde...
Es macht so...
Guck mal.
Sogar Swift.
Ich glaube sogar Swift.
Guck mal.
Sogar Swift.
Apple.
Ja.
Sogar Swift ist Open Source auf GitHub.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube es ja nicht.
Ich glaube es ja nicht.
Aber...
Ich meine, warum macht man eine Sprache heute nicht einfach Open Source?
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum das so ist.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die nicht Open Source...
Guck.
Wird der euch...
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja.
Exzellente Swift.
Das ist hässlich.
Warum sieht in dem Fall Swift so hässlich aus?
Nvidia.
Nee.
Bei Nvidia ist ganz viel Zeug Closed Source.
Die haben einige Sachen.
Auch auf GitHub.
Aber sehr viel Closed Source immer noch.
Ähm...
Golem oder Heise Plus Abo.
Ganz ehrlich, gar keins.
Ich hatte mal ein Heise Plus Abo.
Das habe ich mir gekauft, weil die haben ab und zu noch mal so Gehaltsumfragen und sowas.
Und da wollte ich mal eine lesen.
Hab mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Guck dir das einfach mal an.
Mal gucken, wie Heise Plus ist.
Und dann habe ich ein Heise Plus Abo abgeschlossen.
Und hab festgestellt, es gibt keinen Knopf, um das zu kündigen.
Ja.
Ja, ich weiß.
Es gibt theoretisch einen Knopf, das zu kündigen.
Aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Es gibt...
Das hat dann quasi nur iFrame in iFrame geladen, wenn man auf Kündigen gedrückt hat.
Und...
Du konntest...
Ich kriege es nicht mal genau zusammen.
Vielleicht konntest du auch auf Kündigen...
Vielleicht konntest du auch auf Kündigen klicken.
Dann hat es neu geladen.
Der Kündigen-Button war immer...
Also es hat zumindest nicht gekündigt.
Ich musste dann an den Support von denen schreiben.
Und sowas.
Richtig, richtig nervig.
Und...
Und was auch...
Und was auch abfuck war.
Ich wollte...
Ich wollte einen Artikel lesen.
Halt...
Gehaltsentwicklung irgendwie was.
1900...
Äh, nicht 1900.
2000...
18 oder so.
Und hab ich ein heißes Plus-Abo abgeschlossen.
Und hat es zwei oder drei Tage gedauert, bis ich überhaupt Plus-Zugang hatte.
Ganz weird.
Und dann hab ich versucht zu kündigen.
Und dann hat der Kündigungs-Button nicht richtig funktioniert.
Also ganz merkwürdig, Alter.
Keine Ahnung.
Das hol ich mir nicht mehr.
Und Golem wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht, warum.
Aber...
Wie gesagt, ich glaub's...
Ich glaub es ja nicht.
Aber man weiß es ja nie.
Guck mal.
Jetzt ist...
Wisst ihr, was ich auch sehr merkwürdig finde?
Die haben...
Die haben halt ein GitHub-Repo.
Und es hat 14.000 Sterne.
Die Frage ist nur...
Warum hat es 14.000 Sterne?
Hier ist nichts drin in diesem Repo.
Gut, man kann Issues reporten und sowas.
Ich mein, warum hat man ein GitHub-Repo...
Warum...
Wenn nichts drin ist.
Man hat Examples drin.
Ja, super.
Dafür hat man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt...
Das gebraucht, ja?
Also sprich...
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Und ich verstehe auch nicht, warum es...
Also die sagen ja auch, ja...
Open Source, ja.
Ja, FAQ.
Will Mojo be open sourced?
Over time we expect to...
Ich verstehe nicht, warum es nicht einfach gleich open source ist.
Such as the Sterna...
Is still young, so we continue to...
Incubate...
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Also, verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, ja.
Warum...
Das schafft ja auch ein gewisses Vertrauen in die Sprache und in die Technologie und in die Implementierung.
Wenn das Open Source ist und man gucken kann, okay, was macht das eigentlich genau?
Und das ist halt so ein Ding.
Das eine muss ja gar nicht dem anderen widersprechen.
Man könnte ohne Probleme die Sprache Open Source machen.
Ohne, dass man jetzt instant jeden Pull-Request reviewed und approved.
Ich meine, versuchte mal...
Guck mal, Sachen wie...
Sachen wie .NET oder...
Oder Chrome oder sowas, ja.
Die sind auch Open Source.
Ja, aber contributed mal zu Chrome.
Oder contributed mal zu irgendeinem...
Etwas nicht ganz so...
Zu irgendeinem Open Source Projekt, was irgendeiner großen Firma gehört.
Das ist teilweise...
Da musste durch übelst viele Ringe springen.
Bitte sign hier das Contribution Form.
Ähm...
Und jetzt beantworten uns noch diese 500 Fragen.
Und dann reviewen wir das und lehnen es ab und sowas in der Richtung.
Also, es ist jetzt nicht so, als könntest du da easy irgendwas contributen.
Das heißt, das müssten die auch gar nicht machen.
Aber es ist ein Unterschied zwischen...
Man kann sich den Source Code angucken versus man guckt sich jeden Pull-Request an.
Die könnten auch genauso gut sagen, erstmal keine Pull-Requests.
Wir entwickeln das erstmal, bis es in einem Stand ist, wo wir denken, dass es jetzt...
...sich dafür eignet.
Aber ich finde es halt blöd, dass es nicht direkt Open Source ist.
Ja.
Dann können wir ja mal kurz schauen, was denn...
Ja, gibt's immer mal wieder Fragen dazu.
Discord expanded on the answer.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt in Discord.
Wie wär's, wenn die es einfach in ihre FAQ schreiben, anstatt zum Discord?
Naja, gut.
Ja, aber so viel dazu.
Ausprobieren werden wir sicherlich irgendwann mal, aber ihr wisst ja, ich bin nicht der allergrößte Python-Hacker-Man.
Ja, ich find das keine schlüssige Erklärung.
Ist Delphi nicht Closed Source?
Das kann sein.
Aber du musst mal gucken, aus welcher Zeit Delphi ist.
Delphi kommt von 1987 oder sowas.
Okay, 1995.
Also ist schon ein bisschen...
Da war das generell mit Open Source noch nicht so weit hin.
Muss der Source Code nicht eh installiert werden, damit man ein Programm kompilieren kann?
Nö.
Nö, warum?
Warum?
Du brauchst den Source Code von deinem Programm, was du kompilierst.
Du brauchst nicht den Source Code vom Compiler oder von der Standard-Library oder sonst was.
Oder irgendwelche anderen Entwicklertools.
Du brauchst den Source Code von deinem Programm.
Ansonsten brauchst du das nicht.
Ich mein, guck mal, du kannst ja auch den Microsoft C++-Compiler nehmen, wer sowas machen will.
Man weiß ja nie.
Und damit...
Ich glaube nicht, dass der Open Source ist.
Und damit deine Programme übersetzen.
Du brauchst deinen Source Code, aber den Compiler oder den vom Framework oder Standard...
Standard-Library oder irgendwelche Plugins für die IDE und sowas brauchst du nicht, ja.
Ja, C++ ist halt so ein Ding.
Es gibt halt kein C++, was Open Source ist in dem Sinn.
Es gibt C++-Implementierung.
Es gibt aber halt leider, dass du so findest...
Also bei C ist es nicht so wild.
C ist so simpel und übersichtlich.
Da tut sich auch nicht viel.
Aber bei C++ ist es halt so ein Ding.
Ist auch eines der Kritikpunkte, die ich daran habe.
Warum...
Ich kann es euch sagen, warum es das nicht gibt.
Aber warum...
Gibt es keine offizielle Standard-Implementierung für C++.
Das würde auch dafür sorgen, dass es nicht so einen Wildwuchs gibt, dass es teilweise Features gibt, die im Standard 2005 oder so eingeführt wurden.
Aber noch kein Compiler richtig unterstützt oder der meiste Kram nicht richtig oder undefined behavior.
Ich kann euch sagen, warum es keine Referenz-Implementierung von C++ gibt.
Weil dann das C++-Gremium ihren eigenen Scheiß benutzen müsste, den sie sich ausdecken.
Und da haben die keinen Bock drauf.
Das war es, die sich ausdecken.
Niemand will das implementieren.
Keiner Bock drauf.
Dass irgendwelche Armsäcke, die an GCC oder LLVM oder wo auch immer dran arbeiten...
Ne, wie heißt das?
LLVM?
LVVM?
LLV...
Alter, wie heißt das nochmal?
Ich glaube so, oder?
Ja.
Arbeiten.
Nein.
Es gibt einen C++-Standard.
Es gibt keine C++-Referenz-Implementierung.
Dieses Standards.
Es gibt ein paar Textdokumente, wo ganz wildes Zeug drinsteht bei C++.
Aber es gibt keine offizielle Referenz-Implementierung.
Weil dann müssten sie ihren eigenen Müll benutzen.
Und vielleicht feststellen, dass es scheiße ist, was sie sich ausgedacht haben die letzten 15 Jahre über.
Zumindest in großen Teilen.
So, was haben wir denn heute auf YouTube zu gucken?
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Schwarze Hände.
Jetzt...
Sieht jetzt die Zukunft bei dir ein.
Ich nicht.
Kommt drauf an.
Ja.
Cyberpunk 2.0.
Der einzige...
Was ist?
Technik-Job als Quereinsteiger.
Krisensicherer Beruf als Aufzugstechniker.
Oh ja, Aufzüge braucht man immer.
Wir sollen mal gucken.
Chat-Gip.
Ich wollte ja noch gucken, was auf der Seite da ist.
Was auf GitHub so trendet.
Habe ich noch gar nicht gemacht.
Ist GCC nicht die Standard-Implementierung?
Nee.
Und dafür hat GCC auch einiges vom Standard gar nicht drin.
Es gibt eine schöne Übersichtsseite.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die jetzt finde.
C++-Implementations.
Overview.
Standards.
Ich weiß nicht.
Da gab es irgendwo was.
So eine schöne Seite mit so einer hässlichen, schlecht gemachten Tabelle.
Wo drin steht, welche Compiler was unterstützen.
Hier vielleicht.
Ja.
Genau.
Oh nein.
C++.
Es ist soweit.
MonkaS.
Es gibt C++-Sekt.
Okay.
Es geht weiter, Leute.
Es geht weiter.
Okay, lasst uns mal kurz...
Was gibt es für C++-2026-Features?
Gibt es noch?
Gibt noch nichts.
Es gibt noch nichts.
Nee, gibt es noch nicht.
Ja.
Also, zumindest hier gibt es eine Übersicht, was die Compiler alles supporten.
So.
Da sieht man schon mal, dass...
Okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen unfair.
Ja.
Weil C++-26 ist in Ordnung, wenn die das noch nicht alles supporten.
Aber gucken wir uns mal die Zweitage an.
Guck mal, wie man hier schon sieht.
Die 2023 an.
Ja.
Und es gibt keine Referenzimplementierung.
Guckt, guckt.
Es gibt auch Sachen.
GCC mag vielleicht noch mit die Kompletteste sein.
Aber auch GCC hat nicht alles.
Nee.
Nein, es gibt, glaube ich, es gibt, glaube ich, nicht einen C++-Compiler, der den Standard komplett implementiert.
Wo man auch schon mal sieht, dass es irgendwie komplett an der Realität vorbeigeht.
Gehen wir mal weiter.
Okay, das sind 3.
23 Features.
Das ist ja okay.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht noch super aktuell und so.
Gehen wir mal weiter.
20 Features.
Ja, da sieht...
Da sieht GCC...
Modules.
Ja, das Modules wird wahrscheinlich so ein Ding sein.
Da können wir in C++ in 50 Jahren noch mal gucken.
Und die hantieren noch mit Header-Files rum.
Ja, da sieht C++ und...
Ja, manche sprechen das Klang aus.
Doch relativ gut aus, aber auch nicht alles.
Ja.
Hier sieht es ganz gut aus.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal bei 17.
Da ist mittlerweile alles dabei.
Guck, da haben sie alles...
Also, ja, C++ ist das...
Äh, GCC ist das am nächsten, was wir haben am Standard dran.
Ja.
Aber der Witz ist halt...
Der Witz ist halt, wenn man sich das hier anguckt...
Diese...
Die Sachen hier, es ist halt...
Hä?
Wollte ich eigentlich nicht...
Die Sachen sind halt...
Die Sachen sind halt wieder absolut...
Absolut nicht verständlich, ja.
Nehmen wir mal das als Beispiel.
Na gut, das kann man...
Die Syntax...
Die Syntax ist so klar...
Und das ist jetzt noch hübsches C++, ja.
Die ist so unglaublich hässlich immer.
Ich meine, wer zum Teufel...
Das liest sich so kacke einfach nur.
Und das geht jetzt noch.
Das geht jetzt noch.
Das geht noch viel schlimmer.
Naja.
Okay, lass mal kurz gucken.
Was trennt denn die Woche?
Game Engine?
Ja, da hat der Unity-CEO mit zu beigetragen.
Open Tofu Manage Your Cloud Infrastructure.
Okay, was ist das?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Gibt's da...
Gibt's da irgendein...
Irgendein Beispiel?
Open Tofu.
Infrastructure as Code Tool.
Okay.
Docs Introduction.
Äh...
Get in it.
Terraform.
Hä?
Und warum brauche ich da jetzt noch Tofu obendrauf?
Okay.
Es wäre mega nice, würden die einfach mal erklären.
Ah, Multicloud Deployments.
Das heißt, es gibt...
Ist das eine Sammlung von Terraform-Modulen oder sowas?
Ach, das ist Terraform.
Terraform, das ist der Terraform-Folg.
Siehste mal, ging komplett an mir vor.
Ich wusste, dass die Terraform-Folg...
Ich wusste nicht, dass man das Open Tofu...
Ach, das ist der Terraform-Folg.
Jetzt ergibt...
Okay, dann verstehe ich auch, warum das so viele...
Ja, nice.
Das müssen wir auch gleich mal starren.
Ja, hier.
Ja.
Okay.
Das ist...
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Terraform-Folg.
Interessant, ja.
Sehr schön.
Das finde ich gut.
Ich bin gespannt, ob sich das durchsetzt.
Aber...
Dann haben wir vielleicht eine gute Alternative.
Mal schauen.
Text-to-Speech.
Okay.
Plain.
Jira.
Open Source Jira.
Was soll das sein?
Ein Open Source Jira?
Das ist...
Das ist im Prinzip ein Ticketsystem, oder?
Weil es sieht gar nicht aus wie Jira.
Es ist...
Hat bloß jemand hingeschrieben, weil es cool klingt, oder?
Jira.
Es sieht ehrlich gesagt komplett anders aus.
Und es ist ein...
Pricing?
Okay.
Also immer.
Jira.
Das ist kein Web.
Das ist kein...
Browser-Tool.
Das ist...
Irgendwie so Elektronen-mäßig, oder?
Hätte ich jetzt vermutet.
Ich meine, man kann das sicherlich selbst hosten.
Und dann ist es free, solange man will.
Ich würde nachher angucken.
Ja, Start with Docker Compose.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall zum Selbsthosten.
Naja, gut.
Jira.
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
AI.
Eine weitere Node.
Taking Application.
Da gibt es ja auch 30 Milliarden von für.
Aber sicherlich ohne Mobile-Apps.
Und deswegen schon meistens nicht brauchbar.
Bivi.
Hysteria.
Das ist China-Chinesen-Proxy.
Very good.
Very good whiteboard.
AI.
Power... PowerShell.
Oh.
Was rennt der denn?
Warte schön.
PowerShell.
C++-Shit.
Kamal.
Was ist das?
Deploy Web-Apps everywhere.
Was?
Dynamic Reverse-Proxy Traffic Call Recruiter.
Ist das...
Ist das eine...
Ist das so eine Art...
TCP-Session...
Sharing...
Ding für mehrere Backends oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Was ich gerade mache?
Ich gucke, was auf GitHub trendet.
Checke ich nicht, was es ist, ehrlich gesagt.
So genau.
Also die, die...
Keine Ahnung.
Tabby.
Ah, Moment.
Das ist jetzt...
Ist das nicht...
Ne, Moment.
Das ist nicht das Terminal, wo du den Login brauchst, oder?
Äh.
Äh, das ist irgendwelches AI-Zeug.
AI.
Äh, Game Engine.
Okay.
Note.
Most advanced front-end track-and-drop-Builder.
Also quasi was wie Frontpage.
Ähm.
Hackerman-Zeug.
The Universal Proxy Platform.
Das ist doch bestimmt auch irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding, oder?
Okay.
Was ist das jetzt?
Kann man das aufmachen, ohne dass man auf irgendeine...
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
FAQ.
Was bin ich sehen?
Ist das...
Das ist doch bestimmt irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding.
Ja.
Ist es.
So ein China-Chinesen-Ding, um die China-Firewall zu umgehen.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Jo.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Hi, Max.
Wie findest du Custom-Tastaturen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab nie eine gehabt.
Hast du schon mal was mit F-Sharp gemacht?
Nee.
Hab ich nicht.
Weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Es werden auch immer noch Leute gesucht für Kobol.
Ah.
Okay.
Nice.
Nee.
Hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ja.
Nee.
Hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
F-Sharp gibt's keine Ahnung.
Drei Entwickler auf der Welt oder so.
Auch nicht, warum das Microsoft...
Die...
Also ganz ehrlich.
Wahrscheinlich würde Microsoft besser tun, so eins, zwei richtig beliebte Features von
F-Sharp nochmal nach C-Sharp zu bringen und dann F-Sharp einfach F-Sharp sein zu lassen.
Ey.
Dann würde ich auch sagen, Keckleaf.
So.
Was können wir uns denn angucken?
Der Aufzug...
Wir gucken uns jetzt den Aufzug...
Ich will jetzt wissen, was der Aufzugstechniker verdient.
Was...
Was verdient...
Der Aufzugstechniker...
Ist die nicht eigentlich schon recht alt?
Was meinst du?
F-Sharp?
Nö.
Also...
Im Vergleich zu...
Top alt...
Das...
Weil F-Sharp gibt's seit...
Was weiß ich...
2014 oder so was.
Möglich.
Was?
Naja.
F-Sharp gibt's...
Gibt's...
Ähm...
Auch nicht so lange.
Was?
Ach so.
Ja, das war erst ein Research-Projekt, was keiner benutzt hat.
Ja.
Genau.
Seit 2010.
Visual Studio 2010 wurde das erstmalig unterstützt.
Ja, genau.
Wollte grad sagen 2002.
Null.
Ne, ne.
2010.
Ja, das kommt eher hin.
Also wirklich benutzt hat das kaum einer bis 2014, 2015.
Das ist so die Zeit, wo dann auch so langsam ein bisschen so der...
Sagen wir mal, nicht der Hype, aber so diese...
Diese...
Die Leute realisiert haben, dass funktionale Elemente von Programmiersprachen durchaus was
ganz Praktisches sind.
So.
Zum Beispiel hat fast jede Sprache heute sowas ähnliches wie Pattern Matching.
Oder...
Anonyme...
So Inline-Funktionen und sowas.
Hat eigentlich mittlerweile jede größere Programmiersprache.
War mal gut, mal schlecht.
C++ hat von allem plus das Schlechte bekommen.
Und...
Das Gute in abartiger Syntax.
Guckt euch die Lambda-Syntax in C++ an.
Oder die Async...
Hat jemand mal die Async Await-Syntax in C++ gesehen?
Nein.
Das ist jetzt unfair. Das sind nur die quasi nur
der theoretische
Aufbau in unterschiedlichen Standards. Aber wie das aussieht
schon, ey.
Wisst ihr,
alle anderen Sprachen schaffen es irgendwie
so, okay, das ist
das ist Feature XY und
so ist ein minimal Beispiel, wie du es
verwendest. Aber nein, nicht C++.
Wenn ich sowas hier schon
sehe. Auto Standard
Forward
Policy und Standard
Launch Differential
Ah ja,
Beste. Ist so schlimm.
Guckt euch diese Syntax an, Mann.
Was ist das? Guckt euch,
das ist so eklig. Standard
Async, Standard
Launch Async. Das ist die
Lambda Syntax von C++.
Alter, ist das
scheiße, Mann.
Äh, und wo?
Hier.
Guck mal hier. Auto A3
Was?
Hier, Standard
As, aber...
Wait.
Auto, Auto A3.
Standard Async, Standard
Launch, X. Okay,
was ist X? X, also ich würde
sagen, X ist nicht definiert, aus
meiner Sicht, oder? Ne, Moment.
Moment, Moment.
X ist, was zum Teufel ist
Ah, X ist ein Struct.
Obviously, natürlich ist
X ein Struct, okay.
Es ist quasi ein Default-initialisiertes
Struct.
Wo jetzt, wo die
Call, wo der Call-Operator
oder wie auch immer man das Ding
nennt, der Aufruf-Call-Operator
überladen ist,
sodass man ein Struct direkt als
Funktion aufruft. Meine Fresse, C++
allein schon das Beispiel ist wieder,
ist ein gutes Beispiel für
wie beschissen die Sprache ist, Mann.
Also, nur mal so, nur mal so.
Nur, nur, nur, nur, dass wir das jetzt mal
nur, nur, dass wir das jetzt mal richtig checken. Also.
X ist ein Struct.
Dadurch, dass man sagt, man möchte
eine Variable anlegen
vom Typ X mit dem Namen X
auch schon ein geiles Beispiel, ohne dass
man irgendwas dahinter schreibt zum Initialisieren
wird es Default-initialisiert. Also alles mit
0 höchstwahrscheinlich, was nicht schlimm
ist, weil es gibt nichts zu Initialisieren.
So, dieses Struct hat
ein paar Methoden drauf, unter anderem
ein Operator-Overload
nämlich für Function
Calls, sodass man
auf dem Struct selbst
Function Calls machen kann,
die dann hierhin weitergeleitet
werden. Das heißt, im Endeffekt
ruft
X
Klammer auf, Klammer zu
quasi
das hier auf.
So unglaublich abartig, Mann.
So, und da kommt dann raus
I plus 10. Okay.
So, und das wird dann Standard
Async, Standard Launch
X und als Parameter
43.
Moment.
Auf was bezieht sich die
43? Ach so, auf den, auf den,
äh, hier.
Auf das Int an der Stelle.
Da kommt dann, da kommt dann raus 43 plus
10. Oh Mann.
Und das ist, das ist noch nicht alles.
Es gibt ja noch,
das ist, das ist ja nur die, das ist ja nur die halbe
Miete.
Genau, es gibt ja noch Core-Await.
Es ist so aber
nicht, keine Ahnung, niemand, niemand.
Deswegen, das ist übrigens der Grund, warum es keine
Standard-Implementierung von C++ gibt,
weil die Leute, die diesen Standard machen,
keinen Bock haben, den eigenen Kack
zu implementieren.
Danke
für die Subs, Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Ich guck
grad mal nach. Oh, irgendwie
muss ich mir was zu trinken holen gleich mal.
Du, du, du, du.
Splixer, wilder
Igel, Stripes, Pog-Subscriptions
heute, Leute.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass C++ von allen
gehasst wird, außer irgendwelchen merkwürdigen
Leuten.
Hm.
Niemand mag C++, selbst die Leute, die C++
täglich machen müssen, mögen C++ nicht.
Hi Max, ich mache gerade Ausbildung in
System-Integration. Kannst du mir was empfehlen, wo
ich später arbeiten könnte? Ja, in so ziemlich allem.
Kommt drauf an, was dich interessiert.
Du hast
früher mal was von Cloud gesagt. Hab überlegt,
in die Serverwartung,
na, Server, Serverwartung
gibt es nicht.
Müsste nicht was Serverwartung sein, sondern was verstehst
du unter Serverwartung?
Dass man ab und zu mal eine Festplatte taucht?
Dafür braucht man kein FISI.
Das kann jeder Hausmeister
im Rechenzentrum.
Da brauchst du, da musst du
nichts machen.
Und das macht auch jeder Hausmeister am Rechenzentrum,
weil du heutzutage als FISI
beziehungsweise als
ITler kaum noch ins
Rechenzentrum musst, wenn du nicht gerade bei dem jeweiligen
Cloud-Provider oder Provider arbeitest.
Oder beim Infrastruktur-Team.
Ein Kumpel
von dir, der kümmert sich per Fernwartung um
Server in einer Firma.
Ach, sowas meinst
du das? Ja, gut.
Ich, ja, ja.
Der administriert Server für
irgendwelche Unternehmen. Ja, gut,
ich mein,
wenn die selbst keinen haben, sind das wahrscheinlich
irgendwelche super kleinen Klitschen,
die dann wollen, so nach dem Motto, ey, wir
brauchen,
was weiß ich,
eine Seite,
wo draufsteht, dass wir Urlaub haben.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, was der da genau macht.
Aber das ist nix, wo Mitte irgendwie
die großen Skills
und so eine Art Karriere
hast, würde ich mal sagen, wenn du ab und zu mal
per Fernwartung für irgendwelche kleinen Klitschen
Server
rebootest und updatest. Keine Ahnung.
Gut, ich kann das schlecht einstellen, ich weiß ja nicht, was der
macht. Keine Ahnung.
Das kann ja alles und nichts sein.
Aber Serverwartung sagt halt
gar nichts aus. Sind das Linux-Server,
Windows-Server, was genau läuft da drauf?
Was macht er da?
Wo laufen die Server? Ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Laufen die bei der Firma irgendwie im Rack,
im Keller? Laufen die bei irgendeinem
Cloud-Anbieter?
Muss da irgendwelche
Containerisierungssachen orchestriert werden?
Das kann ja alles sein, also das
kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Serverwartung ist wirklich sehr nichtssagend.
So, ich wollte
jetzt mal gucken, was der...
Was ist eigentlich die Sprache, die du auf
der Arbeit nutzt, wenn du mal was skripten musst? Bash.
Tatsächlich, Bash.
Wenn es was kleines ist, dann muss ich immer Bash.
Genauso wie hier im Stream.
Bash.
Für so kleinen Kram immer Bash.
Ist mit Abstand das Einfachste,
um irgendwas schnell auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Bash.
Und wenn es ein bisschen was
komplexeres, umfangreiches ist, dann ist es
dann mache ich das
meistens in C-Sharp.
Hat dann zwar nichts mit, wir skripten mal schnell was
zusammen zu tun,
aber das ist meine Lieblingssprache und
wo ich mich im Framework auch am besten auskenne.
Und wenn es ein bisschen was
komplexeres ist, gerade was vielleicht auch irgendwie
so irgendwie
CLI-Interface
braucht, also nicht Interface, sondern
Kommandozeilen, Argumente und sowas,
dann mache ich das ganz gerne da drin.
Kannst du ja mittlerweile
auch AOT kompilieren.
So dass es, wenn du es richtig machst,
dass es rückwirkend läuft auf nahezu allen
Linux-Distributionen. Vielleicht nicht ganz so
krass kompatibel wie Go. Go ist ja
Go-Binaries
sind ja kompatibel rückwirkend
bis Linux-Kernel
2.6.38
von 2008 oder sowas.
Wenn du aktuelle
C-Sharp AOT kompilierst
in einem
Docker-Container, kriegst du es rückwirkend
zu laufen bis glaube ich
Linuxe von 2014
oder so. Das reicht aber in der Regel
auch. Was läuft
nur richtig unter Windows? .NET?
Nein, .NET läuft seit Jahren schon
Cross-Plattform. Das läuft sogar besser
unter Linux würde ich fast sagen mittlerweile
wie unter Windows.
Also du hast ein paar Sachen, die sind
Windows-Only. Beispielsweise Windows
UIs. Also du kannst Windows Forms und
WPF nicht unter Linux
benutzen, weil das
DirectX verwendet oder eben Windows-API
aufrufe.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Das ist ja nur
ein kleiner Teil davon, der nicht
mal so richtig sogar dazu gehört.
Das sind so Add-Ons quasi fast schon
mittlerweile.
Ansonsten
ganz ehrlich, wenn ich
eine
Web-API-Backend
oder Web-Backend baue in .NET
dann würde ich das immer unter
Linux laufen lassen als unter Windows.
Und das funktioniert richtig gut
seit Jahren schon.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die Leute immer noch im Kopf haben,
dass .NET so Windows-Only ist.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich historisch daran,
weil Microsoft in der Vergangenheit
ein bisschen Kacke war.
Microsoft ist immer noch
Kacke.
Aber Microsoft hat auch ein paar gescheite
Sachen mittlerweile.
Kannst du meine krasse Online-Business-
Card raten?
Was soll das sein? Hast du irgendeine
Hast du eine Webseite,
wo du draufgeschrieben hast,
so bewerbungsmäßig, was du alles
gemacht hast schon, oder wie?
Oder was ist eine
Online-Business-Card?
Okay, okay.
Gucken wir mal.
Linux executable.
Okay, das
ist Hex. Muss ich das jetzt in
irgendein Hex-Dump-Ding
reinpasten, dass ich rausbekomme,
was auf deiner Seite draufsteht?
Das ist...
Und noch ein Barcode unten drunter,
jetzt wird's aber langsam richtig
pfeifert.
Ne, da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Aber ich glaube, für die passenden
Interessenten ist das sicherlich nicht schlecht.
Kannst du aber einfach
sagen, was rauskommt.
Das ist doch...
Okay, wenn das irgendein Binary ist,
müsste das hier oben...
Oh, das ist irgendein Header für irgendwas?
Keine Ahnung.
200 Byte pro Gramm.
Also, sehr
geekmäßig.
Ich denke, das könnte durchaus die passenden ansprechen.
Gib das mal
einem BWLer da so... Ja, das kannst du vergessen.
Aber ich glaube, daran richtet sich das auch nicht.
Der checkt da nix.
Habe ich die Woche irgendwelche
IT-News-Sachen irgendwie verpasst?
Achso, Heiser hat ja immer noch keine Wochenübersicht.
Konnte man das
nicht irgendwie sortieren nach
meist kommentiert oder sowas?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das habe ich gelesen. Da haben
die Leute sich ja schon wieder überschlagen.
Oh nein, Svelte 5 wird jetzt wie React.
Weil irgendwie ein Wort
ähnlich ist. Effekt.
Aber die, ganz ehrlich,
die sind eh komplett pepega, die Leute
wieder. Okay, dann
lasst uns mal anschauen.
Was
macht denn der Aufzugstechniker?
Was ist neu?
Noch gar nix.
Es gibt noch nicht mal ein Release-Datum für Svelte 5.
Es gibt bloß ein Blogpost über ein
neues Svelte 5 Feature.
Und zwar, wenn ich das ja aus dem Kopf
richtig zusammenkriege, dass nicht mehr
standardmäßig alles Reactive ist.
Oder zumindest, doch,
das stimmt nicht. Dass du es so
einstellen kannst, dass nicht mehr jede Variable
Reactive ist, sondern dass du
explizit sagen musst, was wie Reactive
ist. Und das haben sie eingebaut,
dass bei größeren, komplexeren
Seiten und Komponenten
klar ist, was
bei State Changes passiert.
Ich fand das relativ
einleuchtend. Ja.
Aber Reddit und Twitter
und alles, oder sorry,
X, sind natürlich bei den
News wieder komplett eskaliert, weil sie
gesagt haben, oh nein, das ist der falsche
Weg für Svelte. Das ist nicht die
gleiche Syntax wie vorher. Das geht
nicht. Svelte ist jetzt React. Warum
sollte ich da nicht gleich React verwenden?
So. Okay,
hatten auch ein paar Beispiele hier drin.
Genau, und dass sie sagen, das ist einfacher
als Stores zu verwenden.
Genau, du kannst jetzt
$State verwenden anstatt Store.
Und du kannst Effekt und sowas.
Also im Prinzip, es ist
gar nicht so schlimm, aber die haben
wieder einen kompletten Weltuntergang
herbeigeredet da
in den Kommentaren.
Es macht Stores einfacher und für größere
Komponenten macht es klarer, was wie wo
Reactive ist. Ich weiß es nicht.
Wir warten, mal abwarten einfach, was
dann da kommt. Ich meine, was ist das Problem?
Ja, es ist
JavaScript-Drama.
Okay, lasst mal schauen.
Technik-Job als Queereintrag.
Riesensicherer Beruf als Aufzugstechniker.
Der einzigste Hinweis, den ich
habe, ist Aufzug außer Betrieb.
Ja, das ist ungefähr das gleiche,
das ist ungefähr das gleiche,
wie wenn man im IT-Support arbeitet.
Da kriegt man auch so tolle Hinweise
wie, es geht nicht. Ja, was denn?
Ja, das, was ich den ganzen Tag benutzen muss.
Okay, was benutzen Sie denn den ganzen Tag?
Ja, wie? Das müssen Sie doch wissen.
Also, glücklicherweise
habe ich nie im
IT-Support gearbeitet und werde
auch nie freiwillig im
IT-Support arbeiten. Aber ich
habe da schon ein paar Sachen mitbekommen, weil ich
habe im gleichen Büro gehockt,
wo nicht wirklich unser
IT-Support, auch wenn ich immer jetzt Support gesagt
habe, gesessen haben, aber Leute,
die sich mit internen
Problemen als quasi First Level
auseinandergesetzt haben.
Es war eine gewaltig richtig großes
Büro und die saßen dann auch da drin und dementsprechend
habe ich da ein paar Sachen mitbekommen. Also, mal
meine persönliche
Lieblingsanfrage,
auf die ich mal reagiert
habe, war,
da kam eine Mail, das System
ist kaputt und das System
geht nicht.
Das war komplett falsch
bei mir. Ich war
damals im Linux-Administrationsteam
und das
war von irgendeiner Arztpraxis
in
Marburg oder so.
Ganz wirr.
Ganz wirr, wo ich mir gedacht habe, was
zum Teufel will die?
Ja, Marburg
Arztpraxis, was? Hä?
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, die ist
komplett falsch bei uns.
Was
nicht heißt, dass wir nicht um drei Ecken
irgendwas mit denen zu tun haben, vielleicht.
So, damals, und da
habe ich darauf geantwortet, dass ich glaube, sie sind
hier falsch,
aber wenn sie mir sagen,
um, ja,
aber wenn sie mir sagen, um welches
System das geht,
dann
können wir das vielleicht an die richtigen Leute
weiterleiten.
Und ihre Antwort auf meine Mail
war, ja, ich meine das System,
mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Da habe ich auch gedacht,
ja, okay, weißt du was, ich reagiere
jetzt nicht mehr. Die war bei uns
eh falsch. Also, ich wüsste nicht, was wir
mit irgendeiner Arztpraxis in Marburg
zu tun hätten.
Also,
ich habe das dann
mal weitergeleitet an Windows-Leute,
weil ich mir dachte, ey,
die wissen da schon mehr Bescheid,
weil bestimmt keck Windows,
das ist ja ganz, ganz
weirdchamp
Windows.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ihr dann dort geholfen
wurde bei Windows.
So.
Ach, jetzt, wo ich gerade
das Ding noch
jetzt, wo ich gerade
das Emote hier sehe.
Leute, ich habe letztens
noch ein Anime geguckt. Ihr wisst ja,
ich bin sonst nicht
so der Ultra-Weep, was das
angeht.
Und
nein, nein, es war nichts,
was ihr jetzt vielleicht denkt.
Aber so ein bisschen,
ich habe ein bisschen Damage davon
getragen, weil ich mir gedacht
habe, als ich das geguckt habe,
was guckst du da eigentlich?
Und warum?
Und warum guckt das jemand?
Und warum guckst du das weiter?
Wie hieß das?
Irgendwie, irgendwas
I'm maxed out
my level oder sowas?
Ja.
Das hier.
What the fuck?
Was bin ich
sehend, Alter?
Bis ich dann irgendwann gelernt habe,
bis ich dann irgendwann gelernt habe,
das ist ein Konzept,
das in Japan
sehr beliebt ist.
Und zwar, dieses Genre
nennt sich
Cute Girls
Doing Cute Things.
Und im Prinzip
war das auch so.
Nein, nein, nein, es ist nicht NSFW.
Keine Sorge.
Im Prinzip ist es
komplett belanglos.
Keine Ahnung,
was, warum,
warum das überhaupt Leute gucken.
Ich check's nicht.
Aber ich hab natürlich,
ich hab natürlich alle 12 Folgen geguckt.
Und wenn ich erstmal irgendwas anfange
und am Ende hab ich mir gedacht,
okay, warum hab ich mir das,
warum hab ich mir das angeguckt?
Na gut.
Okay, der Aufzugstechniker.
Der Abstürzende.
Der Abstürzende ist schlecht.
In meinem Job geht's mir als Handwerker
tatsächlich sehr, sehr gut.
Alter, warum haben die so viel Tossmusik?
Hallo, ich bin Patrick,
34 Jahre alt, Servicetechniker
für Aufzüge hier in Berlin.
Let's go.
Boah ey.
Ich sag euch mal, das wär nix für mich.
Wenn ich da schon reinguck,
Wenn ich da schon
reinguck und man muss da oben irgendwo
rumtouren vielleicht oder so, da hätt ich wirklich
keinen Bock drauf. Ich hab jetzt zwar nicht unbedingt
direkt Höhenangst,
aber
ich erkenne auch, dass
ab einer gewissen Höhe gefährlich ist.
Und ich war letztens mal,
als ich, als ich
wandern war, da gab's oben auf dem Berg
so nen Turm, da konnte man
keine Ahnung, irgendwie 300 Stufen
oder so hoch, also der Turm ging irgendwie
nochmal 50 Meter oder so,
bin ich in so, und oben war so ne,
so ne Aussichts, so ne Aussichtsplattform,
bin ich da
raus und das Gelände
auf der Aussichtsplattform, das war
ungefähr so,
oh, so Bauch hoch,
Bauch hoch, ja, also
mit Anlauf hätte man da ohne Probleme
drüberspringen können.
Und da war's mir schon ein bisschen komisch,
als ich da runtergeguckt hab, muss ich sagen.
Oh, doch ist, ist
schon ganz schön hoch, ja.
Ist, ist schon ganz schön hoch.
Dann dir viel Spaß, bis nachher.
Tschüss, mein Schatz.
Wir haben auf unserem Diensthandy
eine firmeigene App, wo unsere
Aufträge abgebildet sind.
Das heißt, ich kann teilweise schon
meine Arbeiten eigentlich schon
Wochen im Voraus planen. Siehste, siehste,
da, da sieht man wieder den Unterschied
zwischen irgendwelchen privaten Unternehmen,
wo das sinnvoll gemacht wird, mit Technik,
und irgendwelche Ämter.
Während Ämter sich die neuesten,
weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist,
Corona-Zahlen irgendwie per Fax
zuschicken, kriegt der morgens
seine Aus-, äh, ich wollt grad sagen,
Ausflüge, kriegt der seine Ausfahrten
und Aufträge direkt aufs Tablet
per App. Da sieht man halt, da kann man
sagen, ja, funktioniert's,
auf der anderen Seite funktioniert's halt nicht.
Tagesaktuelle Störungen können dazukommen,
oder auch Personeneinschlüsse,
wo ich dann hin muss,
um die Person zu befreien.
Es gibt den, äh,
Das hatte ich auch mal. Ich war auch mal im Fahrstuhl gefangen.
Bei, beim, beim letzten
Arbeitgeber im alten Gebäude.
Da, das war,
weiß ich noch, das war der mittlere Fahrstuhl.
Fax ist sicherer
als immer. Ne, fang jetzt davon nicht wieder an.
Das weiß ich noch, das war der
mittlere Fahrstuhl. Und wir waren
mit, ähm,
glaub, drei, ja, mit drei Leuten
waren wir im Fahrstuhl.
Und der Fahrstuhl ist
runtergefahren
ins nächste
Stockwerk und ist angehalten.
So, und
der ist, also,
ich hab mir schon gedacht, als der gefahren ist,
hab ich mir gedacht, okay, irgendwie
ist der jetzt ein bisschen früh stehen geblieben
und dann ist die Tür, also, er hat
versucht die Tür aufzugehen und dann hast du
unten gesehen, also, wir waren dann quasi
nur so zu, zu
zehn Prozent im richtigen Stockwerk.
Der ist einfach, also der, der Fahrstuhl
ist einfach über dem Stockwerk angehalten
und so, so unsere Füße hätten
quasi rausgucken können.
Versucht die Tür aufzugehen und dann haben wir halt festgestellt,
oh, guck mal, da,
ja, da, da, da ist,
da ist das Stockwerk, aber wir sind zu hoch.
Das ist angehalten.
Da standen wir dann da drinnen.
So, und natürlich
hatten wir dann wieder irgendwelche
Spaßvögel, ey,
jetzt erzähl das nicht, natürlich hatten wir dann wieder
irgendwelche Spaßvögel dabei,
die dann angefangen haben, da drinnen
rumzujumpen
und rumzudingsen, aber das hat nicht, hat nicht
funktioniert. Naja, lange Rede,
kurzer Sinn, wir haben dann ein bisschen, wir haben dann ein bisschen
die Knöpfe gespammt, bis das Ding
weitergefahren ist. Das ist natürlich nicht runtergefahren.
Da ist dann die Tür wieder hochge, ist
die Tür wieder zugegangen, dann ist das ein Stück
hochgefahren und da konnten wir dann raus.
Also, irgendwas ist da, ist da
komisch gewesen. Keiner hatte
Bock, dann noch eine Station runterzufahren,
ist dann wieder hochgefahren.
Wenn das jetzt, wenn das jetzt anhält,
also wenn das jetzt, wenn das jetzt gar nichts macht.
Und einmal muss man sagen, teilweise sind die
Leute schon Endschalter im,
vielleicht, ja. Zumindest,
also eine Sache,
wo, wo mal eine fast geheult hat
im Fahrstuhl, aber das war auch richtig
assi von den, von den Leuten, die dabei waren.
Also sind wir, sind wir im anderen Gebäude,
in Frankfurt gibt es ja Gebäude, die sind relativ hoch,
ja, sind wir hochgefahren. Ich glaube,
das Gebäude hatte sechs,
sechsundzwanzig Stockwerke oder so in dem Dreh.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wieviel es genau, also in dem Dreh
fünfundzwanzig, sechsundzwanzig Stockwerke,
konntest du auf jeden Fall ein Stück hochfahren.
Und das sind halt so, wie, wie es halt in so Lobbys sind,
ja, zwei Fahrstühle gerade
vor dir, zwei Fahrstühle
hinter dir, gibt es ja oftmals so, so Gruppen
an Fahrstühle.
Und steigen wir, steigen wir
in den Fahrstuhl ein, fahren hoch.
Das ist, das ist das Gebäude, wo,
wo ich euch erzählt habe, dass das Rechenzentrum
im,
im sechsten Stock ist oder,
ja doch, im sechsten Stock ist,
weil
im Keller,
also im Keller wäre das Rechenzentrum eigentlich
besser gewesen, aber das Rechenzentrum
dürfte damals nicht im Keller gebaut
werden, weil dann
die Vorstandsparkplätze
hätten weichen müssen und die
Vorstandsparkplätze waren natürlich wichtiger,
als das Rechenzentrum an einer sinnvollen
Stelle zu bauen und deswegen hat man dann das
Rechenzentrum im sechsten Stock gebaut
und hatte dann später richtig krasse
Statikprobleme mit
schweren Storage-Systemen,
dass sie nicht durch die Decke brechen.
Da hat man dann eine ganze Weile gebraucht,
bis man irgendwelche Architekten gefunden hat,
die das Ganze schön
gerechnet haben, dass man das betreiben durfte.
Naja, stellt euch mal vor,
ihr sitzt im fünften
Stock, die Decke
bricht und es fällt auf euch
irgendwie ein, was weiß ich,
20 Tonnen schweres Storage-System drauf.
Also ihr könnt froh sein, ihr werdet
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr allzu viel davon mitbekommen,
aber ihr seid ziemlich Matsch.
Also ich verstehe schon, dass sie sich da
ein bisschen schwer getan haben, das zu genehmigen.
Was wollt ihr jetzt erzählen? Zumindest sind wir
in den Fahrstuhl eingestiegen
und da kam noch eine,
die irgendwie in ihr Büro wollte
und
weiß nicht, ob die irgendwas
erzählt hat, aber du hast dir
zumindest angemerkt, dass Fahrstuhlfahren
nicht so das ist. Und natürlich,
wie das ist, du hast da so ein paar ganz lustige Leute
drinnen, die haben das,
wahrscheinlich hat sie es gesagt,
die haben das natürlich gleich wieder auf die Spitze
treiben müssen, die haben dann angefangen
im Fahrstuhl rumzuspringen, eigentlich mega assi
und dann hat der Fahrstuhl,
der hat ja irgendwelche, frag mich nicht, wie das
funktioniert, der kann ja irgendwie messen,
wie viel Spannung oder so
auf dem Seil drin ist
und dann sind die Leute
im Fahrstuhl rumgesprungen, ja,
und dann hat der Fahrstuhl halt
auf einmal so einen Satz gemacht,
so wupp, kurz
und dann gebremst
und die hat halt, die hat halt
angefangen zu heulen im Fahrstuhl,
weil sie halt so Schiss hatte
vor Fahrstuhlfahren und
ich meine, das ist auch übelst assi,
wenn du weißt, dass du einen im Fahrstuhl
stehen hast, der Schiss hat, Fahrstuhl zu fahren,
ihr kennt das vielleicht, es gibt so Leute,
die müssen dann aus Prinzip
sowas machen,
weil sie wissen, dass irgendjemand anderes Schiss hat,
das ist genauso, wie wenn du weißt, dass irgendjemand
Angst vor, keine Ahnung,
Schlangen, Spinnen,
Reptilien, was auch immer
hat und dann musst du machen,
dass erwachsene Leute, ja,
ja, die waren sehr erwachsen, die waren, also ob die
geistig, weiß ich nicht, aber
die waren alle 30
plus damals schon
und du wirst dann, wir sind da drin rumgesprungen,
ging dann auch weiter,
aber es ist trotzdem mega assi gewesen,
ja, Treppe steigen ist das eine, aber
wenn du, wenn du irgendwie, frag mich nicht,
im 24. Stock willst oder so, dann ist
das mit Treppe steigen nicht so, nicht so geil,
warum heißt das Fahrstuhl, keine Ahnung,
ich konnte Aufzug sagen,
so,
erstmal gucken.
Servicetechniker für Aufzüge oder
Aufzugstechniker, Aufzugsmonteure, den gibt's nicht,
in der Regel ist es so, dass man als
Quereinsteiger mit
gewissen Vorkenntnissen dann
dort einsteigt.
Hat er ein Loch im Ohr?
Okay, Realschule,
Mechatroniker, öffentlicher Dienst, da hat er keinen Bock mehr
drauf gehabt, kann man ja auch verstehen.
Instandhalter, Metallindustrie,
Aufzugstechniker.
Na?
Ich bin jetzt
Höhe Messe,
ja, aber das dauert ja nicht mehr lange,
da bin ich schon da.
Diese ewige Parkplatzsuche in der Stadt.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Es ist in Berlin, okay, da haben wir
Glück, dass er keinen richtig
krassen Berliner Dialekt hat,
weil ganz ehrlich, Leute, es gab
ja mal so eine Umfrage
vor ein paar Jahren, was der
irgendwie der beste
und der nervigste deutsche Dialekt ist und ich glaube
bayerisch war der beste
in dieser Umfrage und sächsisch war der
irgendwie, ja,
nervigste Dialekt. Das kann ich überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehen. Ich finde
weder bayerisch schlimm
noch sächsisch schlimm. Der
einzige, okay, es gibt
zwei Sachen an Dialekten,
die ich nicht mag in Deutschland.
Einmal ist Berliner Deutsch,
so, ich kann das gar nicht
nachmachen.
Wie auch immer,
ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht geben, Alter.
Berliner Deutsch finde ich so ultra cringe,
das ist schlimm. Und was ich
auch nicht mag, ist
Schwäbisch.
So isch des.
Ich mag die Schwaben.
Schwäbisch geht,
aber Berliner,
so Berliner Deutsch finde ich ganz grausam.
So isch des.
Ja, ja, genau.
Das ist so schlimm.
Leute, Sekunde.
Ich muss mal ganz kurz ein Wasser holen zu trinken.
Ich hab bestimmt wieder ein Lid
herausgeschwitzt vorhin.
Guck mal, dauert
eine Minute. Kurz mal Glas unter
Wasserhahn halten.
Magst du das trinken?
Sehr gut. Das ist ohne Sprudel.
Ich habe jetzt einfach aus dem Wasserhahn ein bisschen.
Ich muss unbedingt was trinken.
Einen Tee habe ich schon leer, aber nachdem
ich heute Morgen drinnen war, wie man hier sieht,
guckt, 8 Uhr 31,
24. September.
Da habe ich ein bisschen was
rausgeschwitzt, das muss jetzt wieder rein.
Gut, übrigens, wo ihr es
gerade dabei habt,
lasst mich mal kurz
gucken, was meine Stonks machen.
Was machen meine
Stonks? Meine
Stonks sagen...
Oh.
Ist wieder ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Könnte man noch mal was kaufen?
Not so
Stonks, sagen die. Ja, das ist korrekt.
Wenn das noch ein bisschen fällt, kaufe ich
noch mehr Stonks.
Wie viel habe ich denn hier noch drauf?
Wie viel kann ich denn noch kaufen?
Ah, noch 614 Euro. Na, das lohnt sich
jetzt nicht wirklich.
So. Weiter.
Ja, es lohnt sich insofern nicht,
das hier irgendwie noch reinzustecken.
Also,
ich überweise halt regelmäßig
was. Und manchmal
bleibt halt ein bisschen was übrig.
Weil es halt nicht glatt aufgeht
mit dem, was man
kaufen kann. Hast du Bitcoin?
Ne. So, aber wir wollen uns
jetzt eigentlich den Aufzugstechniker angucken.
In dem Bereich, wo wir heute arbeiten,
der Berliner Kudamm, das ist...
Berliner Kudamm, ist das irgendein
Assi-Viertel oder geht das noch halbwegs?
Ich kenne mich in Berlin nicht aus. Also in
Berlin war ich bisher nur
am Hauptbahnhof,
am Brandenburger Tor, am
Reichstag heißt das, glaube ich, gell?
Und...
Ja, in diesen Parks dazwischen.
Viel habe ich
nicht gesehen von Berlin.
Also, eine Sache,
die mir in Berlin extrem aufgefallen
ist,
und das liegt wahrscheinlich halt
durch diese Ost- und Westgeschichte,
dass es Straßen gibt,
da ist links
alles neu und glänzt und
rechts ist alles alt und verfallen.
Das habe ich so krass noch
nirgendswo gesehen.
Echt. Katastrophal.
Wow, Alter, mach nicht so laut.
Sag mal, wer mischt diese
Sendung ab?
Exzellent, Musik hier.
Mon Castille.
Mon Castille,
Einfach stehen bleiben.
So, Handwerkerparkausweis ausfüllen.
Ja, im Gebäude
kannst du halt nicht rauchen, ne?
Muss man alles irgendwie...
Warum ist dein Arm so schwarz?
Ist das ein Handschuh
oder ist das eine Tätowierung?
Aber ohne geht auch nicht.
Das ist irgendwie
eine bescheuerte Angewohnheit.
Tätowierung?
Das ist wie so ein Ritual.
Der ist ja komplett schwarz, der Arm.
Mit Betreten vom Gebäude
geht's dann weiter mit
Arbeitsschutz.
Morgen!
Guten Morgen.
Ha?
Ich stehe auf dem Kuhdamm, oder?
Auf dem Kuhdamm?
Weil, wenn er an den Etagen
vorbeifährt, in der Abwärtsfahrt,
kommt DX und fällt ab.
Ja, UX bleibt angezogen.
Genau, UX bleibt die ganze Zeit angezogen.
UX bleibt angezogen.
Würde ich auch so sehen.
Also,
wenn ich oben einsteige und mir jede Etage
von oben nach unten wünsche, fährt er
alle brav ab.
Das macht er in der Aufwärtsfahrt nicht.
Dann machen wir jetzt nämlich folgendes,
weil wir einen
Schutz tauschen wollen.
Ein Schutz?
Jetzt bin ich auf der sicheren Seite.
Jetzt gibt's...
Ah, guck mal, jetzt wird erstmal gemessen.
So ein Teil hab ich auch.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Ein Duspol oder so, gell?
Heißt das so?
Wo sind die Elektrikors-Experts hier?
Tauschen.
Und die 14.
Ah, guck mal,
die guten Wera-Kraftform-VDE-Schraubendreher.
Die guten Wera-Kraftform-VDE-Schraubendreher.
Ach nee,
Duspol ist der Hersteller.
FR haben wir ausgebaut.
Bezeichnen wir das Bauteil noch.
Eine kleine Probefahrt.
Ist wie mit der Flex oder wie mit dem Dremel.
Dremel ist ja auch nur der Hersteller.
Ihr hört schon,
das schaltet jetzt auch akustisch viel sauberer.
Das schaltet jetzt auch akustisch viel sauberer.
Er hält an in der Etage.
Macht was er soll.
Alle unsere Sachen weg.
Licht aus.
Genau, also mit dem Auto,
das ist so, dass ich den
zur Privatnutzung auch überlassen
bekommen habe, im Rahmen der
1%-Regelung.
Ich find das super cool.
Wenn man nicht viel Auto fährt,
warum nicht?
Du zahlst keine Versicherungen,
keine Steuern, Wartung,
Instandhaltung, TÜV etc.
ist alles mit drin.
Ich find's immer interessant,
dass man über die Jahre
immer anhand der Geräusche erkennt,
was der Aufzug gerade macht.
Ja, kann ich verstehen.
Ist bei vielen Technikgeräten so.
Und ihr werdet's kennen
vielleicht von euch,
sowas simples wie euer Computer,
wenn der jeden Tag neben euch
steht und an ist, ihr erkennt
an den Geräuschen teilweise
schon sowas, wie schnell die Lüfter drehen,
Festplattenaktivität und sowas.
Ungefähr, ob was
nicht stimmt, ja.
So wenn auf einmal beispielsweise die Festplatte
rattert, denkt ihr auch, hä, was ist jetzt los?
Dann seht ihr, ah, okay,
der Windows-Search-Indexer macht wieder irgendeinen Scheiß.
Das erkennt man mit der Zeit.
Und so ist das bei Aufzügen wahrscheinlich
dann noch ein bisschen mehr Mechanik,
aber das ist ja drin auch so.
Wer hat noch Festplatten?
Ich hab noch ne Festplatte drin,
weil irgendwo braucht man ja auch was mit ordentlich Speicherplatz.
Also ich hab, ja,
ich hab
SSD,
Kack-SSD
und noch ne ältere SSD
und noch ne Festplatte.
Das mit, übrigens, das was hier steht,
stimmt nicht so ganz.
Die ist einfach nicht gemountet.
Die, also,
die ist Veracrypt-encrypted
und das sieht man hier nicht.
Oh, jetzt wird geklettert.
Abseilungs-Champ.
Das ist das erste und letzte Mal.
Bei dem Aufzug hier ist es nun mal so,
dass es diese Absturz-Gefahr gibt
und dann muss man halt
darauf Rücksicht nehmen.
Waderbumsdings, sag ich für den Zap.
Bist du, bist du
MaxFP, ich bin wobblos.
Wir bräuchten hier
nen Geländer, was mindestens 700 hoch ist.
Dann wäre im Prinzip...
Aber die Frage kommt öfters.
...Gefahr beseitigt.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Habe ich nicht einfach nur genug G-Baden
oder G-Badest du mich jetzt?
Also muss das Geländer einfach mal
ein paar Zentimeter höher.
So 25 Zentimeter mehr.
Früher hat das ausgereicht.
Heute nicht mehr.
Und dazu mache ich jetzt ein paar Bilder
hier von der Konstruktion.
Und dann wird ein Angebot erstellt,
damit das Geländer vergrößert wird.
Und dann wird der Aufzugbetreiber
sagen, fix mein Aufzug
und nerv mich nicht mit dem Geländer.
Ich bin davon überzeugt,
dass ich einen absolut krisensicheren Job habe.
Berlin ist geografisch begrenzt.
Es werden immer mehr Leute in der Stadt.
Es wird immer mehr gebaut.
Die Breite können sie nicht mehr.
Also müssen sie hoch.
Die Leute haben keine Lust, hoch zu steigen.
Also was brauchen sie? Einen Aufzug.
Ich kenne keinen arbeitslosen Aufzugsmonitor.
Schlüssige Argumentation, klingt nachvollziehbar.
Ja, da gibt es sich immer sehr viel Mühe.
Wenn man dann sagt,
ich hätte gerne eine kleine Stulle.
Dann wird das hier immer so ein Semi-Sandwich.
Aber auch wieder mit...
Mir wird das wahrscheinlich gar nicht reichen.
Gurke und Krimsgraben aus dem eigenen Garten.
Das Modell von Aufzug ist ziemlich...
Alt?
Tricky.
Na gut, dann fahren wir da einfach mal hin.
Locker, flockig.
Leute, ratet mal, was es bei mir zu essen gibt heute.
Der einzige Hinweis, den ich habe,
ist, dass es hier nicht so viele
Aufzüge gibt.
Aufzug außer Betrieb.
Du lernst jeden Tag dazu.
Jede Störung ist ja nicht wie die andere.
Jeden Tag, wenn du nach Hause kommst...
Nudel mit Lachs.
Ich wusste, dass das jetzt kommt.
Nein.
Es gibt heute kein Nudel mit Lachs.
Ich wollte es nur hören,
ob ihr es noch wisst.
Nein, es gibt heute keine Nudel mit Lachs.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was es heute gibt.
Ich glaube,
ich habe noch...
Gibt es noch nicht Nudeln mit Tomatensoße?
Was gibt es denn?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube...
Was gibt es denn?
Ich glaube, Reis gibt es noch.
Reis...
Ich glaube, Reis mit...
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Wieder ein Stück Wissen mehr in deinen Wissenskoffer gepackt.
Tricky Fahrstuhlmodell.
Ich schaue jetzt in die Steuerung rein.
Was hier so los ist.
Ich klicke.
Das sieht nach einer Türstörung
der Kabinentür aus.
Ich möchte erst mal
den Dreck hier raus machen.
Was mich auch stört,
ist, dass manche
Menschen
kein Verständnis dafür haben,
dass ich meine Arbeit machen muss.
Da werden dann Flaschen nach dir geworfen.
What?
Nach dir wird gespuckt, du wirst beschimpft.
Warum zum Teufel soll ich eine Flas...
Na gut, wir sind in Berlin, dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Das ist alles nicht so normal.
Aber warum sollte man nach einem Aufzugsmonteur
eine Flasche werfen?
Ich meine, will man nicht, dass der Aufzug wieder funktioniert?
Aber es ist Berlin, das dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Ich meine, in Frankfurt kann dir das auch passieren.
Aber Berlin ist nochmal,
was das angeht, wahrscheinlich nochmal eine härtere Nummer.
Früher
bei der Bahn, da ist einem schon
sowas öfter untergekommen.
Wir haben ja zwar den Fremdkörper jetzt entfernt
aus der Türschwelle,
aber hier sind verschiedene Sicherheitskontakte.
Der ist verbogen, ne?
Der scheint auch schon mal ein bisschen nass geworden zu sein.
Bisschen rostig.
Den machen wir neu.
So.
Alter, was ist da los?
Ich wurde bei einer Personenbefreiung, also
da war jemand im Fahrstuhl
eingeschlossen, oder?
Ich wurde bei einer Personenbefreiung schon mal
mit einem Messer bedroht in Düsseldorf.
Musste dann die Polizei...
Ja, aber warum?
Wollten die nicht,
dass du die Person rausholst?
Oder was?
Warum bedroht man denjenigen,
der den anderen
aus dem Fahrstuhl befreien will?
Also, was...
Weiß man, was das...
Ich nenne mal, das
Motiv von dem war?
Also, was der sich gedacht hat dabei?
Ich meine,
wenn du da jetzt anrücken würdest,
und sagen, okay,
um den Fahrstuhl
wieder funktionieren zu machen,
muss ich das Kabel abschneiden
und du crashst jetzt halt
50 Meter runter, kann ich auch nichts machen,
dann würde ich mich auch versuchen zu wehren.
Aber wenn du versuchst, einfach die Leute
rauszuholen...
Hä? Okay.
Keine Ahnung, was mit denen los ist.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn einer vorbeikommt
und mich aus dem Fahrstuhl rausholt.
Die Leute sind einfach nur pepega.
Low IQ.
Und...
Wer weiß, was die sich noch alles reingeschmissen haben.
Ja, aber gerade deswegen müsste man sich doch eigentlich
freuen, wenn derjenige kommt, der einen rausholt, oder?
Ja, ich sag ja nur,
dann könnte ich es ja verstehen, wenn sich einer aufregt.
So...
Ich will jetzt nicht crashen mit dem Fahrstuhl.
Einfach so...
Hey, ich hole dich jetzt aus dem Fahrstuhl raus, in dem du eingesperrt bist.
Nein! Komm nicht näher!
Hä?
Ja, das stimmt schon, gut.
Wer weiß, es ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
wie in Frankfurt, wenn du da
durch irgendwelche
Straßen gehst, dort
wo halt die ganzen
Super-Assis rumhängen.
Da kloppen sich auch öfters mal random Leute
auf der Straße, oder
flitzen von 0 auf
100 schräg über die Straße
und schreien rum und sowas.
Es ist nicht direkt
Hauptbahnhof, es ist eher so Nidderstraße
und so ein bisschen drumherum. Aber
trotzdem, da weißt du auch nicht,
was da die nächste Minute
passiert.
Unterschied...
Das hier ist
der Alte, der ist
verbogen. Das ist der Neue. Aha.
Der ist wieder in Originalposition.
Ja. Beste.
Feste ist in Originalposition.
Ja.
Werakraftform.
VDE.
Set.
Feste ist halt der Kumpel. Prima.
Probefahrt nochmal.
Also, mein Gehalt ist
in Anlehnung an den IG Metall Tarifvertrag
und mit der Lohngruppe,
in der ich eingruppiert bin,
habe ich immer so ein bedingungsloses
Bild von etwa
3.900 Euro brutto.
Dann komme ich in einem
sehr schlechten Monat mit
wenig Zuschlägen auf
bei Steuerklasse 1
etwa auf 2.600,
2.700 Euro netto.
Es gibt bei uns natürlich...
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht krass viel.
Auch gerade
für 5-3 Stunden. Aber ich denke mal,
das ist durchaus
durchaus okay.
Viele, viele
Zuschläge für Arbeiten
im versetzten Dienst,
am Wochenende, in der Nacht,
am Feiertag, was man halt
so kennt. Kommt jetzt noch Urlaubsgeld,
Weihnachtsgeld, Prämien,
die wir bekommen dazu,
gehen die netten
Beträge natürlich noch höher.
Ja, das ist doch nicht schlecht.
Dann doch schon auf ein
relativ hohes
Jahresgehalt von
56.000, 78.000 Euro dann kommt
als Handwerker. Und das ist, finde ich,
auch normal, muss ich sagen.
Guten Tag.
Stürmische Begrüßung.
So.
Hi.
Wo ist unser Ritual?
Da ist es.
Jetzt mal Bröchlein kraulen,
wenn er hier nach Hause kommt.
Wuppet.
Jetzt gehen wir also eine Gassi, oder?
Und zwar meine Tochter,
mein Stiefsohn, meine Partnerin
und meine Wenigkeit.
Wir haben das Haus hier zu sehr,
sehr moderaten
finanziellen Aufwendungen
erhalten, weil das
über ihre Eltern quasi gekommen ist.
Das macht mich echt
entspannt, dass ich weiß,
125k für ein Haus ist, glaube ich,
echt wenig.
Das ist meins. Theoretisch kann es
mir keiner wegnehmen.
später im alter bin ich halt einfach abgesichert was mein wohnort angeht also
ich bin der klassische sparer ich investiere nicht in irgendwelche
kriptowährungen oder in andere mobilien oder aktien oder sowas günstiger ist nur
erben schönes motorrad aber das ist auch eigentlich der einzigste luxus den ich
mir persönlich gönne habe ich jetzt seit zwei jahren habe ich gebraucht
gekauft habe sie relativ ich sage immer gerne preiswert bekommen
oh shit ich weiß was es ist das ist ein main aber das kann ich jetzt nicht
spielen weil tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors tors
tors tors tors tors tors das läuft immer noch im hintergrund
vorprobe könnte haben
dann ziehen wir uns jetzt einmal um beziehungsweise ich ziehe mich einmal
kurz um und dann haben wir jetzt drüben bei der feuerwehr was zu tun
dann nehme ich euch auch mit also wir haben jeden dienstag übungsdienst da
treffen wir uns immer um 19 uhr machen aus- und fortbildung mahlzeit schön dass
ihr es geschafft habt ich kann nur echt froh sein dass es so viele gibt die das
freiwillig machen
ich kenne auch einen der bei der freiwillige feuerwehr das sind immer so
ganz spezielle spezielle leute die das freiwillig
machen wir hatten auch ein also ich kenne nur
einen dabei der freiwilligen feuerwehr ist und er hatte laufen irgendwelche
lehrgänge keine ahnung kranlehrgang kettensägen lehrgang 1 bis 5
lehrgang alle möglichen dinge und er ist da auch voll drin aufgegangen
wo wo wo wo tors tors tors tors ich weiß nicht was es ist aber es ist bestimmt
tors weil das durch offiziellität ja also bedeutet wir bauen die leiter einmal
vollständig auf sonderscheinlich wieder runterholen
ok jetzt jetzt geht schon ein bisschen berlinerisch los soll soll ich us nicht
ich habe mir diesen diesen wunsch halt erfüllt diesen kindheits wunsch ich will
feuerwehrmann sein und das handwerk wollte ich auch immer machen
und das ist halt diese vereinbarung zwischen l recharge aber echt habe echten ganzen tag was
warst du aber denkst dass du aber echt ganzen tag was DAS runs sand aus dem amenitiesystem describe
zu tun ich habe alles beides zusammen weil ich bin jemand in unserer gesellschaft der gesagt hat
egal was am ende dabei rauskommt ich habe meine zeit dafür investiert und habe wenigstens den
versuch unternommen den menschen zu helfen okay meistens ehrenwerte ehrenwerte absichten tors
tors tors tors tors tors tors ich habe aufgegeben irgendwelche menschen helfen zu wollen einzigen
die nicht helfen sind irgendwelche tiere im tierheim menschen sind mir egal also außer
angehörige nahestehende und unter chat so als wollte ich mal gucken was kann jetzt eigentlich
raus monatlich 3k um das war gar nicht schlecht ich denke für den handwerklichen beruf ist das
bestimmt ziemlich gut bleibt noch massig geld über ja nice aber was man halt bei dem gesehen hat ist
im vergleich zu der exzellente
schubser vermögens nicht vermögens unternehmensberaterin macht er halt auch den
ganzen tag was und irgendwie was sinnvolles der aua willst du nicht mal dem chat was spenden
das ist falsch rum der chat kann prime subscribe oder soll einfach sein lassen ist nichts ich bin
nicht für die ich bin nicht für die saps hier so was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes die was das
war wirklich der bullshitter der bullshitter der bullshitter der bullshitter der bullshitter der bullshitter
der bullshitter der bullshitter schicht hin die die excel-tabellen erstellerin diese damalige
beitrag hatten work salad für den hat es haben wir sonst noch die zukunft ist jetzt endlich an
diese kühler eine iphone 5 das in review okay da bin ich mal gespannt ob sich da etwas getan hat ich
meine ich hab was habe ich eigentlich haben einen iphone 14 glaube ich noch was ist das darf man mal
kurz drauf gucken keine ahnung steht das hinten drauf was man hat wenn ich da muss ich jetzt das
Moment, das sieht man noch. Chatgear, sieht man das in den Settings? Settings. In den Settings. General wahrscheinlich. About. iPhone 14 Pro ist das, genau. Aber nicht das Max. Das Max war mir zu groß.
Und mal gucken, was sich da, gucken, was sich da getan hat. Also ganz ehrlich, ich würde keinem empfehlen, sich das iPhone 14 oder 15 Pro zu, 15 war ich nicht, aber das iPhone 14 Pro, generell Pro, ganz ehrlich, eigentlich preis-leistungsmäßig ist das ziemlich, ziemlich kacke.
Das ist viel zu teuer und die Features, die es da gibt, es ist jetzt nicht so, als würde ich das unbedingt brauchen.
Also ich habe mir das gekauft, weil ich mir gedacht habe, oh nice, 120 Hertz auf dem, also 120 Hertz Display auf dem Smartphone und hier und geil und ganz ehrlich, überhaupt kein großes Ding.
Also wenn man das ausschaltet, man merkt kaum den Unterschied dazwischen. Also man merkt den schon, man merkt den, ja. Also gerade als jemand, der so ein bisschen PC-Gaming-Erfahrung hat und ich merke den Unterschied sofort.
Ja.
Gerade bei Animationen vom Flüssigkeitsgrad her, aber, also es ist, also man merkt den kaum, dass es irgendwie störend ist. Also dass du sagst, oh nee, das ist die Animation, es ist nicht so, dass die Animationen nervig sind.
Also du merkst es in der täglichen Bedienung kaum, da guckst du dir jetzt ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Animationen an, wie flüssig sich Fenster in die Task-Übersicht begeben und nicht, sondern im normalen Bedienen wischst du schnell drüber, da hast du, guckst dir kaum die Animation an, da fällt es kaum auf.
Ja, ganz. Moment, das, es gibt den Microsoft Defender im App-Store? Alter, was ein Schurz. Gut, ich meine, es gibt auch den Microsoft Defender für Linux. Gibt's ja auch Leute, die den verwenden. Schaust du Filme, Serien eigentlich in Englisch? Ja, die meisten, die meisten. Nicht alles, aber die meisten Sachen.
Das ist das iPhone 15 Pro und augenscheinlich ist es ein kleines Upgrade.
Okay.
Ja.
Ganz, ganz.
Und Apple, muss ich ja mal sagen, ganz im Ernst, ne?
Auch wenn die jetzt da ganz toll USBC, das hätten die seit Jahren schon machen können mit USBC.
Und trotzdem haben sie jetzt nochmal eins oben drauf gesetzt.
Wenn du einfach nur irgendein 0815 USBC Kabel anschließt, dann kannst du nur mit USB 2.0 bzw.
Ne, es ist ja nicht USB 2.0, sondern bestimmt USB.
4.2
1x0.5x3
oder so. Also mit USB
2.0 Geschwindigkeit übertragen.
Das ist halt echt dämlich.
Max, welche
IT-Richtung sind am besten bezahlt?
Kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Das, was gesucht wird.
Du kannst mit beidem Geld, du kannst
mit allem Geld verdienen.
Ich würde pauschal, oh du Mist,
Leute, ich würde
pauschal nicht mal sagen, dass
Management unbedingt
am besten bezahlt ist.
Wenn es, sagen wir mal so,
Management ist tendenziell schon immer ganz gut
bezahlt, aber da gibt es auch nicht so viele Positionen.
Und
es gibt auch
wenige Positionen, die man wirklich, also
für mich kann ich jetzt nur sprechen,
die man machen möchte. Da muss man
schon der passende Typ für sein.
Mainframe-Programmierer, ja.
Also ganz ehrlich, du kannst
mit allem richtig gut Kohle verdienen.
Du musst dich halt gut auskennen.
Du kannst auch, wie gesagt, du kannst
als Kobold-Programmierer gut Geld verdienen.
Du kannst wahrscheinlich sogar
als Experte für Windows-Krempel
gut Geld verdienen.
Also insofern, such dir
was raus, was dir gefällt.
Und guck, dass du da drin richtig Ahnung hast.
Weil umso mehr Ahnung du da drin hast, umso höher sind die Chancen,
dass du in dem Bereich arbeiten kannst.
Und umso höher sind dadurch die Chancen,
dass du in dem Bereich arbeitest, der dir Bock macht.
Was ist es denn, was ist es denn?
Was ist das denn hier?
Code-9-PA?
Was ist es denn, was dir so Bock macht zum größten Teil?
Ach ja, und was man auch sagen muss,
was ich finde, ist auch wichtig.
Man muss sich doch recht breit auskennen.
Das schadet nicht.
Ja, man kann seine Spezialgebiete haben.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Das ist auch insofern wichtig,
weil das die Sachen ist,
wofür man am Ende dann auch die fette Kohle kriegt.
Aber breites Know-how in allen Gebieten hilft einem unglaublich,
diesen einen,
in diesem einen Gebiet,
das noch besser hinzukriegen,
weil es reicht oftmals nicht,
sich nur in einem Gebiet auszukennen.
Man muss auch erst mal so ein bisschen drumherum verstehen,
was da eigentlich passiert.
Deswegen kann ich auch nur jedem empfehlen,
der Physik gelernt hat
und jetzt so klassische Admin-Sachen macht,
sich ein bisschen so mit Softwareentwicklung zu beschäftigen.
Und ich kann auch jedem Softwareentwickler
sich nur empfehlen,
sich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen,
okay, wie baut man beispielsweise
ein Content,
wie baut man einen Container für seine Anwendung,
wie lässt man das beispielsweise auf irgendeiner Linux-VM laufen,
wie wird sowas eingerichtet und so.
Das hilft unterm Strich beiden Seiten,
wenn man sich ein bisschen mit dem Bereich der anderen Seite auskennt.
Zumal das eh immer weiter zusammenwächst.
Ich meine, diese ganze DevOps-Geschichte
ist ja das beste Beispiel für,
dass es immer weiter zusammenwächst.
Wenn man das Ganze jetzt im DevOps-Subreddit fragen würde,
da kommen dann Leute um die Ecke und sagen,
actually DevOps ist gar keine Jobbezeichnung.
Ja gut, das ist aber egal,
was die Leute auf Reddit sagen,
weil wenn ihr in ein Stellenportal geht
und sucht nach DevOps,
findet ihr ganz viele Stellen dafür.
Also es ist vollkommen unerheblich,
was Reddit meint dazu sagen zu müssen.
Das ist aber allein schon, dass es diesen Bereich gibt,
spricht ja dafür, dass da die Überschneidungen immer größer werden.
Genau, und außerdem verstehen viele Unternehmen
ein bisschen was anderes darunter.
Studiengebiete, keine Ahnung.
Von Studium habe ich keine Ahnung.
Oder du meinst so Themengebiete,
die man sich anschauen sollte.
Nicht Studium, sondern die man sich anschauen sollte.
Wenn er Netzwerkarchitekt werden will,
ja gut.
Ich würde sagen, es wäre ganz gut,
wenn du dich mit Netzwerktechnik auskennst.
Wenn du dich natürlich auch mit den Sachen drumherum,
also Security, Linux nicht verkehrt.
Ganz viele Kisten von Cisco sind ja heute auch ganz normal.
X86-Dinger.
Teilweise glaube ich sogar auf Linux-Basis,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Aber Netzwerkarchitektur, da musst du schon,
musst dann auch gucken, in welchem Bereich.
Ich meine, das ist ein Unterschied,
ob man klassisch, lokal, vor Ort
oder ob man noch zusätzlich irgendwelche
Cloud-Anbieter anbinden muss.
Und dort dann auch schauen,
okay, wie funktioniert das da?
Und wie kann ich von den Kisten vor Ort,
On-Prem, wie das die coolen Leute nennen,
zugreifen auf alle Cloud-Services
und teilweise wie Cloud-Services vereinzelt
auf manche lokalen Kisten zugreifen.
Du musst dich recht breit auskennen, würde ich sagen.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung.
Ich bin kein Netzwerkarchitekt.
Max, würdest du, wenn du nach Berufserfahrung gefragt wirst,
nach Jahren die Anzahl von der Ausbildung mit aufzählen?
Also normalerweise sagt man ja,
nee, Ausbildung ist keine Berufserfahrung.
Ich persönlich würde das nicht so eng sehen.
Ich finde das nicht schlimm.
Wenn man sagt, hey, ich beschäftige mich,
keine Ahnung, seit 2005,
ich bin seit 2005 in der Branche,
erst, man muss halt,
ich, also ganz ehrlich, ich habe es in meinem
Bewerbungsgespräch, habe ich so gesagt.
So ungefähr, so wie ich es jetzt gesagt habe.
Ich beschäftige mich da schon
professionell seit 2005 mit.
Erst die Ausbildung beim Internet-Provider,
dann das und das und das.
Und da ging ganz klar daraus hervor,
dass ich die Ausbildungssachen mitgezählt habe.
Ja.
Und in deinem Lebenslauf,
in deinem Lebenslauf schreibst du ja eh rein.
Die Station, was du gemacht hast.
Und da geht das ja daraus hervor.
Wenn es jetzt natürlich,
wenn es jetzt natürlich eine Stelle gibt,
wo draufsteht, wir möchten mindestens
fünf Jahre plus
Erfahrungen so und so,
dann kannst du die Ausbildung nicht mitrechnen dafür.
Das ist denen dann wurscht.
Dann hast du ja quasi drei Jahre Ausbildung
oder je nachdem, wie lange du gebraucht hast,
plus zwei.
Also dann wollen die wirklich fünf Jahre
nach der Ausbildung haben.
Aber da gibt es erstaunlich wenig Stellen,
wo eine konkrete Jahresanzahl drinsteht.
Also was ich öfters gesehen habe,
ist so vielleicht was im Bereich von zwei Jahren oder so,
wo dann steht zwei Jahre plus
Java Enterprise Business Erfahrung und so was.
Aber umso länger es wird,
also man sieht,
wir gucken uns ja öfters mal Stellen an,
sieht man eigentlich verhältnismäßig wenig,
dass darüber hinausgehend was steht.
Also manchmal steht da halt ganz abgedrehtes Zeug drin.
Ja, wir hatten auch schon mal ganz vereinzelt so Dinger
wie sieben Jahre mindestens in dem und dem.
Und dann wollen sie am Ende 34k bezahlen oder so.
Ja, also es steht tatsächlich,
also es steht meistens nicht so konkret drin.
Es steht,
es steht meistens irgendwie einschlägige,
mehrjährige Berufserfahrung in dem und dem Gebiet drin.
Man kann da,
man kann da sicherlich fünf Jahre reinlesen.
Aber ja, ich meine,
man darf nicht vergessen,
viele Unternehmen sind heute auch ein bisschen flexibler
bei der Auswahl der Leute,
wenn die sagen,
sie suchen jetzt jemand als Senior Java Entwickler
und schreiben rein mehrjährige,
mehrjährige Erfahrungen im Java Business,
was auch immer,
Enterprise,
irgendwas Bereich.
Und du kommst dann an und sagst,
ja, ich habe vier Jahre Erfahrung
und die haben sich jemand vorgestellt,
der fünf Jahre Erfahrung hat.
Aber wenn du einen guten Eindruck machst
und die können heute eh nicht so wählerisch sein,
weil die schlicht und ergreifend keine Leute finden,
dann kommst du damit trotzdem,
geht das trotzdem.
Deswegen haben vielleicht auch so viele,
drücken sich davor,
um tatsächlich konkrete Jahres,
Jahres,
ja,
Zeiträume reinzuschreiben.
Eine zehn Jahre Kubernetes Erfahrung,
wobei ich glaube,
das geht mittlerweile sogar ganz knapp,
oder?
Ja, okay, fast, fast.
Ab, ab nächstem,
okay, wenn du,
wenn du bei der Kubernetes Alpha Phase schon dabei warst,
dann könntest du zehn Jahre Berufserfahrung haben,
wenn es da so was gab.
Early Access.
Wenn du Kubernetes Early Access mitgemacht hast,
dann kannst du zehn Jahre Berufserfahrung haben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, richtig.
Das steht meistens gar nicht so konkret drinne.
Oh ja, gucken wir mal weiter.
Was macht denn das iPhone 15?
Bro.
Testet und wurde mehr als nur einmal überrascht.
Positiv, aber auch negativ.
Wow, Alter, mach nicht so laut.
Eine Güte, jetzt übertreiben sie aber wieder.
Was rede ich da?
Tausend Apple Designer haben ein ganzes Jahr
am Design des neuen iPhone.
Tausend Apple Designer,
da wundert mich nichts mehr.
Wie soll, wie soll denn ein Gerät von tausend Designern
gleichzeitig designt werden können?
Wie soll man sich das vorstellen?
Ah, okay.
Ich bin, ich bin Designer 714.
Ich bin, ich bin für das untere,
untere zwanzigstel der linken Seite zuständig, oder wie?
... gearbeitet und das Ergebnis,
sieht aus wie ein iPhone 14 Pro,
das aussah wie ein 13 Pro,
das aussah wie ein 12 Pro,
das aussah wie ein 11 Pro.
Gab, gab es nicht im Vorfeld die Gerüchte,
dass die Kameras noch weiter raus stehen?
Wie das iPhone aussieht und wie es sich anfühlt,
sind dieses Jahr zwei komplett verschiedene Welten.
Ist doch auch so, oder?
Das iPhone 15 Pro fühlt sich einfach großartig an.
Der Rahmen ist etwas runder und deswegen wirkt das Gerät
erstaunlich viel dünner und ergonomischer.
Man versteht das echt erst,
wenn man es mal selbst in der Hand hatte.
Außerdem besteht der Rahmen aus Titan,
ein Material, das leichter und gleichzeitig fester ist als Edelstahl.
Auf dem gebürsteten Titan gibt es weniger Kratzer,
Dellen oder ganz einfach Schmutz.
Immer noch genauso anfällig für Schmutz und Staub ist...
Ey, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
also, ich hab mein iPhone eh nur in der Hülle,
weil du kannst ohne Hülle das Ding ja nicht mehr
gescheit auf den Tisch legen,
wegen dieser rausstehenden Kamerawulst hier.
Also man muss das eigentlich in die Hülle legen,
sodass es noch halbwegs flach auf dem Tisch liegen kann
oder halbwegs ohne die ganze Zeit zu wackeln auf dem Tisch liegen kann.
Gerade, dass du auch mal was gucken kannst.
Und dementsprechend hatte ich noch nie irgendwelche Probleme
mit Kratzern oder Beschädigungen an der Hülle.
Also an der eigentlichen iPhone Hülle, bei dem Case.
Wieder das Kameraelement,
die Linsen stehen deutlich weiter heraus,
als bei jedem anderen aktuellen Smartphone
und das ist einfach ungünstig im Fall eines Sturzes.
Ich hatte irgendwie gehofft, dass Apple mal ein neues Design wagt.
Immer wieder dasselbe ist zwar gut für den Wiedererkennungswert einer Marke,
aber...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde, es sieht mega kacke aus.
Diese Kamera, dieses Kameraelement hier oben.
Das ist jetzt nichts Neues,
ich finde, es sieht seit Jahren schon kacke aus.
Das ist jetzt nicht seit Neuestem.
Und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen,
ich finde nicht, dass es die anderen Hersteller
sonderlich viel hübscher hinkriegen,
aber ich finde nach wie vor, dass es kacke aussieht.
Auf der anderen Seite...
Du hast wahrscheinlich gar keine Wahl,
wenn du Kameras haben möchtest,
mit all diesen Funktionen,
im Zweifelsfall auch mit Teleobjektiv und Zoom
und hast du nicht gesehen,
die brauchen halt einfach eine gewisse Größe, Öffnung und Tiefe,
dass es funktioniert.
Also insofern...
Das ist doch schon lange so.
Ganz ehrlich, es gibt doch sogar Studien mittlerweile,
dass Hersteller, nennen wir es mal, Gläubigkeit
für Leute Religionsersatz heutzutage ist.
Also sei es jetzt Apple oder auch die alte Story
Playstation vs. Wixbox und...
Nein, Gaystation vs. Wixbox war das damals noch.
Da gibt es sogar Studien zu, dass so...
Wie nennt man das so?
Herstellerverehrung für Leute heutzutage Religionsersatz.
Also das ist nicht erst seit gestern so.
Und Apple zelebriert das schon jahrelang.
...angweilig für den Kunden.
Was ich toll finde, ist die verbesserte Reparierbarkeit.
Was?
Seriously?
Man kann iPhones neulich gescheit reparieren?
Ach, nur das Glas, okay.
Früher musste das ganze Gehäuse gewechselt werden.
Sowohl das iPhone 15 Pro als auch Pro Max sind 19 Gramm leichter.
Das klingt nach wenig, aber man spürt es.
Und 19 Gramm weniger.
Und das jeden Tag.
Das macht über 7 Kilogramm pro Jahr.
Du findest, der Vergleich hinkt?
Ja, aber ich jetzt nicht mehr, weil das iPhone 15 Pro so viel leichter ist.
Über das Jahr?
Moment.
Es ist nicht, dass es über das Jahr leichter wird.
Der Vergleich hinkt?
Ja.
Und das jeden Tag.
Das macht über 7 Kilogramm pro Jahr.
Du findest...
7 Kilogramm pro Jahr?
Also ich mein...
Man kann alles irgendwie rechnen.
Aber ich finde, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, es ist 19 Gramm leichter.
Und es ist immer 19 Gramm leichter.
Das ist auch über das Jahr 19 Gramm leichter.
Wie viel leichter ist es denn pro 24 Stunden?
Du findest, der Vergleich hinkt?
Ja, aber ich jetzt nicht mehr, weil das iPhone 15 Pro so viel leichter ist.
Wer hat den Mist geschrieben?
Und jetzt...
Wo war ich?
Ja, Wasserfestigkeit 30 Minuten, 6 Meter Tiefe.
Mehr als Google, Xiaomi und Samsung zusammen.
Ach, und bei Freenet bedanken.
Bei Freenet bekommt ihr einfach alles.
Freenet?
Ja, ganz richtig.
Einfach alles.
Mobilfunk, Internet, TV-Entertainment.
Und ihr könnt auswählen, egal ob...
Ist das nicht auch United Internet?
Also quasi...
1&1?
Ja, ist das doch.
Vodafone oder Telekom oder ganz was anderes.
Sie haben alle deutschen Netze.
Und das bedeutet stets attraktive Preise
und wirklich ganz, ganz unterschiedliche Verträge,
wo garantiert ein Richtiger für euch dabei ist.
Ihr könnt euch online umschauen
oder in einem der über 550 Shops.
Überall in Deutschland.
Euch dort die Geräte vor Ort einmal in Ruhe anschauen
und euch unabhängig beraten lassen.
Vielen Dank an Freenet für die Unterstützung bei diesem Video
und dort könnt ihr euch auch alle vier Farben des iPhones mal genauer anschauen.
Weiß, Natur, Schwarz und Dunkelblau,
das oft einfach aussieht wie Schwarz.
Eine etwas eintönige Farbauswahl dieses Jahr,
aber das Naturtitan trifft genau meinen Geschmack.
Sowohl das iPhone 15 Pro...
Da haben wir aber Glück gehabt noch einmal.
...als auch 15 Pro Max sind etwa 1 mm kürzer
und schmaler.
Der Grund sind dünnere Display-Ränder
und ich finde, die sehen super sexy aus.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass mal der Tag kommen würde,
an dem Apple dünnere Display-Ränder als Samsung hat.
Außerdem sind sie rundherum perfekt symmetrisch.
Davon abgesehen ist es dasselbe gute Display-Ränder...
Wait a minute.
Waren die früher nicht symmetrisch?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht,
dass es jeder Hersteller hinbekommt mittlerweile,
dass sein Smartphone auf der linken und auf der rechten Seite
irgendwie gleich dick ist.
...im iPhone 14 Pro.
Es gibt eine akkurate Farbwiedergabe,
tiefer Kontrast und Schwarzwert,
eine hohe Auflösung...
Aber 1000 Designer.
...adaptive Bildwiederholrate von 1 bis 120 Hz
und 2000 Nits Outdoor-Helligkeit,
wenn der angezeigte Inhalt...
Okay, das ist nice.
...energie viel schwarze Fläche hat.
Und apropos schwarze Fläche,
oben ist ein langes Loch im Display.
Da drin steckt nicht nur die Selfie-Kamera,
sondern auch Face-ID.
Das ist eine schnelle, zuverlässige Gesichtserkennung,
die mich immer erkennt,
außer wenn ich eine Sonnenbrille...
Moment, das hat ja nicht nur das iPhone 15,
das haben die eigenen auch schon.
Was dieses Loch da oben aber auch ist,
ist ein adaptives Widget.
Dynamic Island nennt das Apple...
Ja, das ist auch nicht neu.
...und obwohl ich die Idee cool finde,
ist die Nutzung im Alltag eher...
Ganz ehrlich, das hat meins auch.
Ich benutze es nie.
Ich finde es vor allem praktisch,
jederzeit schnell zu meiner Musikwiedergabe
oder der Navigation zurückspringen zu können.
Die Animationen sehen einfach schick aus
und es macht natürlich total Sinn,
dass man da oben direkt Anrufe bekommt
oder über den Fortschritt eines AirDrops informiert wird.
Im iPhone 15 Pro steckt der A17 Pro
und das ist der weltweit erste 3-Nanometer-Prozessor.
Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich?
Es bedeutet, dass auf selber Fläche
mehr Transistoren passen.
Und das bedeutet bessere Performance
und bessere Effizienz.
Apple spricht von 10% mehr CPU
und 20% mehr GPU-Performance.
Die CPU ist in Geekbench 6 rund 40% schneller
als der Snapdragon 8 Gen 2.
Das ist der aktuell schnelle...
Ich meine, das muss man Apple mal lassen.
Die Dinger sind schon geil,
was sie da bauen.
Apple kann natürlich aber auch
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste,
was Preis angeht,
da ihre CPUs raushauen.
Ich meine...
Was ist...
Die Kosten sind halt nicht mehr feierlich.
Aber trotzdem,
das ist schon nicht schlecht,
was sie da auf die Beine gestellt haben
die letzten Jahre über.
Trotzdem wird man es wahrscheinlich kaum spüren
im normalen Alltag bei der Benutzung
zwischen dem 16er und dem 17er.
Und diese offiziellen Benchmarks
sind ja eh immer ein bisschen
vor sich zu genießen.
Nails, der Android-Prozessor
und die GPU etwa 7%.
Im 3DMark-Stresstest
drosselte der A17 Pro jedoch flott um 30%
und nach etwa 20 Minuten um 50% herunter.
Das ist etwas schade zu sehen,
auch wenn die Leistung selbst dann noch höher ist
als von einem Pixel 7 Pro ohne Drosselung.
Im Alltag ist die Performance vom iPhone 14 Pro
nicht zu unterscheiden.
Das war auch schon ultra schnell und flüssig.
Aber dieses Mal gibt es iPhone 15 Pro exklusive Spiele
und nicht einfach irgendwelche.
Richtige Konsolentitel
wie Resident Evil Village,
Assassin's Creed Mirage,
Oh...
Ja, als würde das auf dem 14er nicht funktionieren.
oder The Division Researcher.
Und die haben eine ernsthaft beeindruckende Grafik
inklusive Raytracing-Lichteffekten.
Aber, und das ist ein großes Aber...
Boah, wie ich so keinen Bock hätte,
das auf dem Display zu spielen, Alter.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ein Controller auf dem Display.
Oh, das ist ja ergonomisch und benutzt...
Oh, das ist ja grausam, ey.
Wer zum...
Alter, wer will denn sowas spielen?
...laufen nicht mal ansatzweise
in hattiver Displayauflösung
und man ist praktisch gezwungen,
ein Gamepad zu benutzen.
Ja.
Weil sonst die Hälfte vom Bild
von der Steuerung verdeckt wird.
Ja, und man es nicht
gescheit benutzen kann.
Die Hitzeentwicklung scheint dabei voll okay.
Positiv aufgefallen sind mir mal wieder
die Stereo-Lautsprecher.
Was der A17 Pro leider nicht hat,
ist ein H2-Chip,
wie er in der Vision Pro
und in den neuen AirPods Pro steckt,
der ermöglicht eine geringere Latenz
und ist einfach zukunftssicherer.
Und apropos langlebig,
das iPhone 15...
Was, was hat er nicht?
...ermöglicht eine geringere Latenz,
hat es ein H2-Chip,
wie er in der Vision Pro
und in den neuen AirPods Pro steckt.
Was ist denn ein H2-Chip?
Der ermöglicht eine geringere Latenz
und ist einfach zukunftssicherer.
Und apropos langlebig,
das iPhone wird extrem lange
Software-Updates bekommen.
Wie lange genau, weiß niemand.
Man geht aber von so sechs Jahren aus,
das wäre dann noch bis iOS 23.
Aber jetzt haben wir erstmal iOS 17
und ein paar nette neue Funktionen.
Das ist ja tatsächlich bei Apple ganz gut.
Ich glaube, du hast im Android-Bereich
mittlerweile auch ein paar Sachen,
gerade die offiziellen von Google,
die recht lange Updates kriegen.
Aber das macht Apple schon seit...
Wobei, muss ich sagen,
ich würde ja mittlerweile sagen
Jahrzehnten.
Echt ganz gut,
was die Langlebigkeit der Dinge angeht.
Man kann den Sperrbildschirm feiner anpassen.
AirDrop hat eine coole neue Animation,
wenn man zwei iPhones aneinander hält
und widgets sind jetzt interaktiv,
was mich sehr freut.
Man kann aus jedem Foto
jetzt einen Sticker machen
und es gibt ein Standby-Display,
wenn das iPhone auflädt.
OMG!
Viele, viele kleine neue Funktionen
und ganz allgemein schätze ich an iOS,
wie einheitlich es aussieht
und die ganzen schönen,
verspielten Animationen.
Es ist nicht perfekt.
Ja, die Autokorrektur der Tastatur
ist trotz neuer künstlicher Intelligenz
gefühlt immer noch hundertmal dümmer
als die von Google
und auch das Nachrichtensystem ist...
Ich verstehe das mit dem Autokorrekt nicht.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern,
mit dem iPhone...
Gab es mal ein iPhone 4S oder sowas?
Ach, danke für den Host, Pog.
Ähm...
Hallo, Leute.
Es ist ja kein Host mehr,
es ist ja ein Raid mittlerweile auf Twitch.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Gab es mal ein iPhone 4S
oder war das ein iPhone 6S?
Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht genau.
4S?
Das, wo ich diese Super Mario Ghost-Hülle
drum hatte.
Ja, also genau,
noch das mit dem Knopf.
Das mit dem Knopf noch.
Und...
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern,
dass die Autokorrektur damals
nicht so beschissen war wie heute.
Wenn man das auf die Reihe kriegt,
das so zu verschlimmbessern,
vielleicht liegt es auch daran,
dass ich mittlerweile
englisch eingestellt habe,
also englisch OS-Sprache
und aber deutsches Keyboard-Dings,
wo man dann erkennt,
dass man Deutsch tippt.
Aber ich hatte den Eindruck,
dass es besser funktioniert hat,
der Autokorrektur auf dem 4S damals
beziehungsweise den älteren,
wie auf den neuen,
er gibt ja
normalerweise keinen Sinn.
Du würdest eigentlich davon ausgehen,
dass solche Sachen nicht schlechter werden
über die Jahre, sondern immer besser.
Vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur mein Eindruck,
der falsch ist.
Aber ich habe auch
richtige Autokorrektur-Probleme
mit dem iPhone.
Der korrigiert den übelsten Blödsinn.
Wobei,
es ist nicht alles gut,
also
die blödsinnigste
Autokorrektur,
die ich jemals hatte,
auf dem alten iPhone war.
Erinnert sich noch jemand?
In Call of Duty gab es einen Killstreak,
der sich
Juggernaut nannte.
Hier.
So was.
Das war so ein Anzug,
den man bekommen hat
und dann hat man mehr ausgehalten.
Ich wollte damals
irgendeinen Tweet schreiben,
wo das Wort Juggernaut drin vorkam.
Was meine Apple Autokorrektur
aus dem Wort Juggernaut gemacht hat.
Könnt ihr nicht wissen,
weil wahrscheinlich hat das damals
keiner gelesen auf Twitter.
Jungfernhäutchen.
Moment.
Das geht jetzt aber
in die ganz falsche Richtung,
Apple Autokorrektur.
Ich hab dann gesagt,
nein, nein, nein, ich will schon
das andere Wort haben.
Ja, das war ein ziemlich Fail.
Gibt es denn sonst noch
irgendwas Neues, Tolles
beim iPhone 15 Pro,
das ich unbedingt haben will?
Bis jetzt habe ich nämlich noch nichts gesehen.
Guck mal,
der hat auch einen Roborock S7.
Ich glaube, das waren die letzten,
die man halbwegs gescheit flashen konnte.
Ganz davon abgesehen,
ich habe ja meinen Staubsauger-Roboter
auch wieder ausgemustert.
Gucken wir mal, ob noch irgendwas kommt.
... unübersichtlicher als bei Android.
Aber, was die Anpassungsmöglichkeiten
angeht, würde ich sogar argumentieren,
dass Apple inzwischen sogar
mehr zulässt als Android
und der neue Action-Knopf ist...
Moment. Bei was?
Moment, Moment. Bei was lässt Apple mehr zu?
... als bei Android.
Aber, was die Anpassungsmöglichkeiten angeht,
würde ich sogar argumentieren,
dass Apple inzwischen sogar mehr zulässt
als Android und der neue...
Ne. Ja, okay.
Kann man jetzt drüber diskutieren, was er meint
mit Anpassungsfähigkeiten, aber da würde ich sagen, nein,
weil sowas, also was Automatisierung
angeht, ist Android einfach
meilenweit, immer noch, vor iOS.
Ich meine, du hast mittlerweile
auf iOS, sie haben es ja unbenannt,
mittlerweile in Siri Shortcuts,
also wenn es um so...
wenn es um...
wenn es um Tasks und Ablaufautomatisierung
geht und sowas,
da kannst du seit Jahren ja beispielsweise
Tasker mit seinen 1000 Plugins
verwenden auf Android und Siri Shortcuts,
ich glaube, oder heißt es mittlerweile
nur noch Shortcuts, keine Ahnung, aber diese
Sache, die sie mal aufgekauft haben,
was früher glaube ich Workflowy hieß und dann
irgendwann Shortcuts und jetzt mittlerweile
Siri Shortcuts, also
das ist ja okay, das geht
alles.
Halbwegs klar, sofern die Funktion eingebaut
ist. Aber
du kannst sehr vieles schlicht und ergreifend
nicht machen mit Shortcuts, was du mit Tasker
machen kannst. Ja, du kannst mit Tasker
beispielsweise nahezu alles
in deinem OS in irgendeiner Art und
Weise ansteuern.
Ja, du kannst Settings umstellen,
du kannst, ich glaube,
Displayhelligkeit kannst du auch machen
mit Shortcuts.
Du kannst im Hintergrund ausführen,
was ja unter iOS prinzipiell so
ohne weiteres gar nicht möglich ist.
Du kannst ein Plugin
installieren, dass das an einem MQTT
Server lauscht, daraufhin
dann das Display entsperrt und sowas.
Keine Chance,
das zu machen unter iOS und
keine Chance bzw. keine Hoffnung,
wie ich da irgendwie sehe, dass das jemals
unter iOS möglich ist. Das ist
nicht schlimm in dem Sinn. Man muss
halt einfach nur wissen, wo
da die Stärken des jeweiligen
Systems liegen. Also ich bin der Meinung,
wenn es um Automatisierung
und Customization geht, ist Android einfach das
Beste. Deswegen habe ich auch meine
Heimautomatisierungstablets
sind Android Tablets. Also
ich habe so Dashboards an der Wand, wo man dann
angucken kann,
was weiß ich, wie weit ist das
Auto geladen oder
Rollladen
runter machen oder
checken, ob noch irgendwo ein Fenster auf ist und sowas.
Das habe ich auf Android
Basis. Da kann man dann zum Beispiel so
Dinge machen wie
lausche an einem MQTT
Server und wenn du eine Message
bekommst, dann spiele eine Message,
dann spiele einen Sound ab
oder ich
kann ansteuern,
abends die Displayhelligkeit runter,
tagsüber die Displayhelligkeit hoch und
das alles remote. Das wird
man so mit einem iPhone
bzw. auch mit einem iPad in der
Variante. Kannst du vergessen.
Kannst komplett knicken. Das ist einfach nicht möglich.
Ja. Für tägliche
Nutzung ist mir persönlich
ein iPhone auch lieber.
Also man muss einfach gucken, wo die
Stärken der jeweiligen Systeme liegen.
So dieses ultra religiöse
Fanboy hat eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja. Ja.
Wird mal wieder Zeit, wobei sich
da nicht so viel geändert hat.
Als nächstes muss ich erstmal das Video machen, was ich
seit Monaten schon angekündigt habe.
Nämlich meine
Bewerbung.
Ich wollte euch ja meinen Lebenslauf und meine
Bewerbung zeigen.
Überlegst du dir das neue iPhone zu kaufen?
Ne. Ich habe einen 14 Pro, das reicht mir.
Ich muss ja nicht unbedingt jedes Jahr,
jede eineinhalb Jahre Apple
1,5K oder so überweisen.
Ich meine,
an Amazon ist okay. Ich meine,
Bezos muss ins Weltall fliegen, mal wieder.
Dem überweise ich Geld, aber an Apple muss ich
kein Geld überweisen.
Action Knopf ist ein super Beispiel dafür.
Seit dem ersten iPhone gab es an der Seite
einen Schalter, mit dem man zwischen laut und lautlos
umschalten konnte. Der ist jetzt weg.
Warum? Und an seiner Stelle ein Knopf. Den kann man
frei belegen. Man kann ihn zum Beispiel gedrückt halten.
Das finde ich eine ganz coole Sache.
Das finde ich tatsächlich
nice. Das ist tatsächlich, das ist die erste
Funktion, ohne Scheiß jetzt in dem ganzen
Video. Die erste Funktion, wo ich sagen
würde, okay, das ist was, wo
ich mir denke, ja, das hätte ich gern. Aber
das reicht für mich nicht,
dafür jetzt ein iPhone zu,
ein neues iPhone zu kaufen.
Weil ich habe mein iPhone immer grundsätzlich
lautlos. Und wenn ich
das mal alle Schaltjahre
nicht lautlos
haben will, dann hätte
ich kein Problem, das in irgendeinem Onscreen
Settings Menü umzustellen.
Touchscreen Settings Menü.
Genau die tausend Designer haben an dem
Menü hier gearbeitet. Also das
finde ich nicht schlecht.
... um weiterhin den Lautlosmodus
zu aktivieren. Oder jetzt eben die
Taschenlampe. Oder man wechselt zwischen Hintergrund
Bildern. Oder man startet den Google
Assistant, damit man nicht länger...
Wisst ihr, was noch cooler wäre? Wenn man
Shortpress und Longpress unterschiedlich
konfigurieren kann.
Ob da die tausend Designer dran gedacht haben?
Was meint ihr?
Meint ihr, man könnte vielleicht sogar
Double-Click anders konfigurieren
wie Single-Press und so?
Ich meine, das wäre natürlich noch cooler.
Ja? Wenn du
Single-Click, Double-Click und Longpress
machen könntest.
Das kommt erst nächstes Jahr, stimmt.
Irgendwas brauchst du für nächstes Jahr ja auch noch.
Ja.
Also, ich könnte mir tatsächlich
vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Dass sie da auch dran gedacht haben.
...
an der Backe hat. Sekunde.
Das Menü, in dem man die Funktionen wechseln kann,
sieht ziemlich spektakulär,
aber auch irgendwie untypisch für Apple aus.
Ich finde den Action-Knopf eine super
Sache, würde mir aber wünschen, dass er
geriffelt wäre, damit ich ihn besser von der
Lautstärke-Wippe unterscheiden kann. Okay, ja.
Gute Idee.
Und das ist doch ein guter Zeitpunkt, um
über die Kamera zu sprechen, oder?
...
Also, auf den meisten Seiten,
wo die Leute Bilder posten
und das auf kleinen Vorschau sehen,
wirst du das nicht merken,
zum Bearbeiten, wobei
kann man die RAW speichern?
...
Etwa doppelt so groß, dann aber auch deutlich schärfer, weil es die vollen 48 Megapixel sind.
Das ist mein Lieblingsmodus.
Im Vergleich zum 200 Megapixel Galaxy S23 Ultra sieht man dann aber, dass das iPhone 15 Pro weniger scharf ist und gleichzeitig künstlich nachschärft.
Zweitens, der Nacht- und der Portraitmodus nutzen jetzt auch die Photonic Engine.
Als wenn ich jetzt demnächst mein Fahrrad fotografiere und es schärfer aussieht, dann ist es gar nicht mehr möglich, mein Fahrrad, was ich fotografiert habe,
sondern ein AI-enhanced Bild von meinem Fahrrad.
Künstlich nachschärft.
Zweitens, der Nacht- und der Portraitmodus nutzen jetzt auch die Photonic Engine.
Das ist ein komplizierter Name, der im Endeffekt bedeutet, es sind hellere, schärfere Fotos und das finde ich super.
Drittens, bei jedem Foto wird jetzt die Tiefeninfo gespeichert.
Das heißt, man kann auch im Nachhinein den Portrait-Effekt auswählen und sowohl die Stärke als auch den Fokuspunkt steuern.
Okay, das ist cool.
Das ist nice.
Das wird aber wahrscheinlich auch mit dem alten iPhone funktionieren.
Das ist ein Feature, das es beim Google Pixel schon seit sechs Jahren gibt, aber ich bin nicht nachtragend.
Es ist jetzt da, Apple hat es jetzt auch und ich finde es praktisch.
Viertens, man kann jetzt neben 24mm auch in 8...
Hast du dir schon ein Fahrrad gekauft? Ja, ich habe mir ein Fahrrad gekauft.
Aber das kommt erst am Montag.
...28 und 35mm Brennweite fotografieren.
Letztere ist genau ein 24MP.
Das ist ein Pixel-Ausschnitt vom Sensor und ich mag dieses Blickfeld total.
Welches? Okay, okay, Zack, Zack, Leute.
Ähm, ich habe es hier glaube ich noch auf...
Äh, Moment.
Oh, fuck.
Ich habe zu viel...
Ah, das da.
Habe ich mir gekauft, in blau.
Funmove, genau.
Das da.
Dürft ihr einmal eine Runde über den Preis kecken?
Und das mache ich wieder zu.
Richtiger Schnapper war das, ja.
Total gerne.
Auch bei meiner richtigen Kamera fotografiere ich am liebsten mit einem 35mm-Objektiv.
Fünftens, es gibt eine neue 5-fach-Telekamera, allerdings nur im 15 Pro Max
und die hat einen 25% größeren 12-Megapixel-Sensor und dieselbe F2.8-Blende wie die 3-fach-Kamera.
Ich habe die 3-fach- und die 5-fach-Tele viel miteinander verglichen
und bei 3-fach ist das iPhone 5 und das iPhone 15 Pro natürlich deutlich schärfer als das iPhone 15 Pro Max.
Und bei 4,9...
Äh, warum natürlich?
Ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
Warum ist das Pro natürlich so viel schärfer als das 15 Pro Max?
Ich hatte gedacht, da sind exakt die gleichen Kameras drin.
Habe ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht richtig aufgepasst, aber warum?
Chatgewerde aufgepasst.
Ich habe nicht richtig zugehört.
Bei 9-fachem ist das iPhone 5.
Ich habe die 3-fach- und die 5-fach-Tele viel miteinander verglichen
und bei 3-fach ist das iPhone 15 Pro natürlich deutlich schärfer,
als das iPhone 15 Pro Max.
Und bei 4,9...
Warum?
Weil das digital...
Das sind die gleichen Kameras.
Warum ist da so ein Unterschied?
Ah!
Ne, hä?
Das Pro...
Moment, das Pro ist größer als das schlechte Kamera...
Schlechter als das 5...
15er?
Warum hat das Pro an...
Hä?
Okay, das ist Apple-Logik, das muss ich nicht checken.
Aber warum ist der 5-fach-optische Zoom pixeliger
als der 3-fach-optische Zoom...
Zoom...
Bei...
Hä?
Egal, ich gucke jetzt einfach weiter.
Bei 4,9-fachem Zoom erst recht.
Aber bei 5-fach ist dann natürlich das Pro Max schärfer,
aber gar nicht so viel, wie ich erwartet habe.
Ach so, okay, okay, okay.
Ah, okay, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Der hat bei dem einen, was ein 3-fach...
Okay, das eine hat einen 5-fachen Zoom,
das andere hat einen 3-fachen Zoom.
Der hat auf quasi, auf theoretisch 3-fach gestellt
und bei dem anderen, jetzt hat er die...
Jetzt hier hat er die Native-Auflösung mit dem...
Ja, Fake-3-fach verglichen
und hier die Native-5-fach mit dem Fake-5-fach.
Jetzt habe ich es, glaube ich, kapiert, ja.
Also gerade hier an den Fenstern erkennt man schon,
dass es ein ganz schöner Unterschied ist.
...erwartet hätte.
Das 15 Pro kann erstaunlich gut mithalten,
selbst wenn man 10-fach zoomt.
Klar, das 15 Pro Max ist zweifellos besser,
aber ich hätte etwas mehr erwartet.
Eine Erklärung könnte sein,
dass die neue Objektivtechnik etwas weniger scharf ist.
Hier auch mal neben dem Pixel 7 Pro bei 5-fach
und 10-fach neben dem Galaxy S23 Ultra.
Meine größte Kritik an der iPhone 15 Pro Kamera
ist die Naheinstellgrenze der 5-fach-Tele und der Hauptkamera.
Man muss unverhältnismäßig weit weg sein,
damit das Motiv scharf wird.
Sehr, sehr oft wechselt das iPhone auf die Ultraweitwinkelkamera
und die ist qualitativ deutlich schlechter als die Hauptkamera.
Ich meine, schaut euch an,
was für einen Unterschied das in einem Foto machen kann,
wenn die Naheinstellgrenze gut ist.
Das ist das Xiaomi 13 Pro mit Leica.
Okay.
Das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke,
okay, Hauptsache es funktioniert irgendwie,
ohne dass ich manuell irgendwas machen muss,
weil das ist mir viel zu pfeifert, mich damit zu beschäftigen,
bevor ich irgendwie mal schnell meine Katze fotografiere oder so.
... Linse und die Fotos dort sehen aus wie aus einer richtigen Kamera.
Was die Farbwiedergabe, Hauttöne und den Dynamikumfang angeht,
macht Apple einen extrem guten Job.
Die iPhone-Bilder sind von zu hellen Mitten abgesehen,
verlässlich schön, egal mit welcher Brennweite man fotografiert.
Da werden absolute Amateure,
aber auch professionelle Fotografen ihre Freude mithaben.
Der große 48-Megapixel-Hauptsensor und der Makro-Ultraweitwinkel sind meine Highlights.
Das iPhone 15 Pro unterstützt jetzt 4K, 60 FPS ProRes-Videos,
allerdings nur über USB-C auf eine externe SSD.
Außerdem wird er...
Leute, hat das jetzt irgendeinen Sinn, dass er gerade die Treppe runterläuft?
... Ultraweitwinkel sind meine Highlights.
Das iPhone 15 Pro unterstützt...
Es ist einfach nur, dass ich das besser im Video flow, oder?
Das macht...
Es hat jetzt keinen irgendwie Zusammenhang zum iPhone,
dass er da die Treppe runterläuft, oah.
... jetzt 4K, 60 FPS ProRes-Videos,
allerdings nur über USB-C auf eine externe SSD.
Außerdem wird ein Log-Fahrprofil unterstützt...
Moment, was? Wait a minute.
Habe ich da was von externer SSD verstanden?
Moment, Moment, Moment, noch mal.
Das iPhone 15 Pro unterstützt jetzt 4K, 60 FPS ProRes-Videos,
allerdings nur über USB-C auf eine externe SSD.
Ah, ah, ach so.
Man kann quasi eine externe SSD über USB anschließen,
wo das dann die Videos drauf speichern.
Ja, ja, okay. Finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Außerdem wird ein Log-Fahrprofil unterstützt,
das ermöglicht umfangreicheres Color-Grading.
Nur eine Sache ist mir ganz wichtig zu betonen.
Anders als das Apple in ihrer Werbung mehrfach behauptet,
kann das iPhone selbstverständlich keine Kinokamera ersetzen, aber...
Apple erzählt so einen Stuss.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, dass...
Eines der besten Sachen war immer noch,
auf einen der letzten...
Ach was, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern,
wo sie die Apple Watch angekündigt haben?
Wo dann die Apple Watch der schwangeren Frau gesagt hat,
dass sie jetzt mal ins Krankenhaus muss,
weil ihr Kind auf die Welt kommt?
Wo ich mir so gedacht habe...
Moment, ich dachte, das merkt man eigentlich.
Ist jetzt nicht so, als bräuchte ich da meine Apple Watch für...
Also ich eh nicht, aber...
Ich dachte eigentlich irgendwie...
Vor allem fragt man sich,
wie haben die Leute das früher hinbekommen?
Die hätten das ja fast verpasst.
Ohne iPhone, äh, ohne Apple Watch.
So hoch!
Wo kommt denn das jetzt so auf einmal her?
Ha, ich habe keine Apple Watch,
da hätte ich meine Apple Watch gehabt.
Auf einmal ist es da, hätte ja keiner wissen können.
Also die haben teilweise auf ihren Präsentationen
schon ein bisschen merkwürdiges Zeug.
Wobei das immer noch...
Also der...
Der sinnloseste Teil,
der größte Bullshit-Teil für mich,
in einem von...
Sei es jetzt Apple,
Microsoft, Gaming,
Ankündigungen der letzten Jahre,
war immer noch die Windows-11-Präsentation.
Die Windows-11-Präsentation,
wo...
Wo nichts gezeigt...
Also die ganze Windows-11-Präsentation
war ziemlicher Müll. Aber...
Dieser eine Part,
wo eigentlich nichts gezeigt wurde,
aber wo eine erzählt hat,
dass für sie,
Windows gleich Family ist.
Da musste ich so hart cringen,
wie selten bei irgend so einer Präsentation.
Könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern?
Das war eine Frau, die hat erzählt,
dass sie mit Windows
so schöne Kindheitserinnerungen
verbindet und für sie
ist Windows Family und
sie muss immer dran denken an ihren,
keine Ahnung, verstorbenen Vater und so,
wenn sie Windows benutzt
und das ist so emotional
und alles, wo du so denkst,
gleich heult noch einer in der Präsentation.
Gut, der Windows-11-Präsentator
hat eh ausgesehen, als fängt er gleich,
fängt er gleich an zu weinen. Ich mein,
guckt euch den mal an.
Der war eh, der, er hier.
Ne, wo ist er denn?
Event.
Ah, da muss man wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich... Er hier!
Der sieht, der sieht, der sieht einfach so aus,
als weint er gleich.
Good evening, good afternoon,
wherever you may be in the world, welcome.
I'm so thrilled you're able to...
Guck mal, das zählt ja nicht so heult gleich, Alter!
...today.
I feel both honored
and truly humbled
to represent an incredible team
today. And as we assembled as a team...
Ey, das ist, das ist grausam.
Also, das war wirklich, das, das war echt
eines der schlimmsten Präsentationen, die ich da in
letzten Jahren übergesehen hab.
Hab ich ganz vergessen, wo wir hier stehen geblieben sind.
Okay, dann lass uns mal kurz das iPhone-Video
fertig gucken.
Es ist mit Abstand das beste Smartphone zum Filmen
und mit den ganzen neuen Features... Er muss auch jeden Tag mit
Windows arbeiten, da kann er weinen, ja, hast recht.
...ist dieser Abstand nur noch größer geworden.
Das iPhone 15 Pro hat einen 2%
größeren Akku und einen 3-Nanometer-Prozessor.
Ich hab deswegen eine deutlich
verbesserte Akkulaufzeit erwartet,
aber leider nicht bekommen.
Die Laufzeit ist sehr ähnlich zum Vorgänger.
Ich hab vor allem das 15 Pro Max genutzt
und dort waren es etwa 5,5
bis 6,5 Stunden Display-Nutzung, bis der
Akku leer war. Wenn man aber nur im WLAN
und im Dunkelmodus ist, gehen noch
mal ein bis zwei Stunden mehr. Das normale
15 Pro hält etwa ein bis zwei Stunden
weniger. Keine Rekord-Akkulaufzeit,
aber sie ist auf einem guten Level
und vergleichbar mit dem Galaxy S23 Ultra
oder Honor Magic 5 Pro.
Aufgeladen wird jetzt endlich nicht
mehr über Lightning, sondern USB-C.
Ja, die EU hat Apple regelrecht
gezwungen und was soll ich sagen...
Aber wirklich,
also, die haben das
ja wirklich ausgereizt bis zum letzten
Jahr, dass sie das jetzt machen.
Dankbar dafür. Es fühlt sich
immer noch etwas surreal an, ein USB-C
Kabel in das iPhone zu stecken, aber
es ist ein wahrer Segen. Ich kann mein
MacBook, ein Android-Smartphone, iPads
und alle anderen Tablets, meine Waage
und Akkuschrauber und das iPhone...
Die Zukunft... Moment, sein
Akkuschrauber?
...ein USB-C Kabel in das iPhone
zu stecken, aber es ist ein wahrer
Segen. Ich kann mein MacBook, ein Android
Smartphone, iPads und alle anderen
Tablets, meine Waage und Akkuschrauber
Achso, das geht bei mir nicht
als Akkuschrauber durch.
...und das iPhone jetzt auch mit ein
und demselben Kabel aufladen.
Das beiliegende USB-C Kabel ist außerdem
schön hochwertig mit Stoff umhüllt.
Alle Lightning-Produkte funktionieren weiterhin,
wenn man einen 29 Euro Adapter
kauft. Ja, typisch.
...
Apple ist der erste Hersteller, der den G2-Standard unterstützt.
Ab 2024 werden alle großen Android-Smartphones folgen.
Das ist wirklich super, weil es bedeutet, dass das praktische MagSafe-Zubehör wie Powerbanks,
Halterungen, Trinkflaschen und vieles mehr mit MagSafe dann von allen benutzt werden
können.
Ich hatte viel Spaß mit dem iPhone 15 Pro und das liegt nicht an einer neuen Funktion,
sondern an vielen kleinen Dingen, die zusammen einen großen Unterschied machen.
Das Design, USB-C, der Action-Knopf und auch die Tatsache, dass das Ganze immer noch in
zwei Größen existiert, das ist heutzutage nicht mehr selbstverständlich.
Große Kritikpunkte habe ich eigentlich nicht, das sind mehr so kleine Dinge, die nerven,
wie zum Beispiel, dass die Kameras immer noch wahnsinnig weit rausstehen, die Nahenstellgrenze
aber trotzdem echt schlecht ist und dass diese Telekamera leider nur im Pro Max erhältlich
ist.
Außerdem hatte ich darauf gehofft, dass es schnell laden gehen würde oder dass der
A-Sitz zum Beispiel die Akkulaufzeit deutlich verbessern würde, beides ist nicht eingetreten.
Ich weiß, es ist dieses Jahr eher eine gute Nachricht, denn er ist gesunken um 100 beziehungsweise
100.000 Euro, damit ist es zwar immer noch nicht günstig, im Gegenteil, aber ich glaube
nicht, dass sich beim iPhone 16 Pro viel tun wird und deswegen ist dieses Jahr ein guter
Zeitpunkt, um zuzuschlagen, wenn man ein iPhone möchte.
Wir gucken mal, lass uns mal kurz gucken, was es kostet, nein, das ist falsch, das ist
das normale 15er, 15 Pro.
Ja.
Ja, 1500 Euro, sag ich doch, das ist halt übelst teuer, irgendwann reicht es nicht
mehr, deine Niere zu verkaufen.
Ne, das gucken wir jetzt bestimmt nicht, das ist schon echt krasser Preis, es ist ein bisschen
wie mit Grafikkartenpreisen, wenn ich das vergleiche zu früher für eine High End Grafikkarte,
das ist auch übertrieben gestiegen die letzten Jahre, gut, jetzt ist es wieder ein bisschen
gefallen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es in der Zwischenzeitlich ja echt absolut pervers teuer war, aber wenn
ich überlege.
Die aller allererste Grafikkarte, ich weiß, jetzt kommt wieder so eine Geschichte, Boomer
Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg, ja, aber die aller allererste Grafikkarte, die ich mir selbst
gekauft habe, war eine ELSA E-Razor 2, das war eine TNT 1, eine Riva TNT Karte, das war,
damals war das eine TNT 1.
Ja.
Also die hat damals der High End Shit schlechthin und ich glaube, die hat damals, ich weiß gar
nicht, ob das Mark oder Euro war schon, 1999, es war noch Mark, die hat damals glaube ich
250 Mark oder so gekostet, lass es 250 Euro gewesen sein, ist auch egal.
So, und heute kannst, sage ich mal so, während Corona und danach konntest du ja in eine Null
dranhängen für eine aktuelle Grafikkarte, High End Grafikkarte.
Ja.
Aber mittlerweile sind wir auch noch bei so
1300 Euro oder sowas.
Was kostet eine 4090
gerade?
Alter, ist immer noch mega teuer.
Ist schon ordentlich, ey.
Kannst nix sagen.
Preislich geht das schon gut ab.
Krasses Ding.
Aber, gut.
Was kostet...
Warte mal. Moment, Moment.
Chatge?
Ausrufezeichen PC.
Mal gucken, was meine aktuell kostet.
Ah, ein Schnapper.
Bei Berserker 1806.
Ja, da wollte ich schon immer was kaufen.
Ihr auch?
Berserker
1806.
Vertrauenswürdigste Shop-Name ever.
Ah, danach gibt's
mein Factory 50 Euro mehr.
Zum Angebot.
Guck mal, jetzt kommt Berserker.
Was hat er so für Bewertungen?
Konnte man sich hier...
Ach, das ist Shop Paradise 24.
Hä?
Zeigt Geizhals irgendeinen Blödsinn an?
Ist schon teuer.
Zumindest, so viel
hast du, wie gesagt, also...
Das war meine allererste Grafikkarte.
Und überlegt euch mal.
Ist irgendwie 250 Mark...
Lass es 250 Euro sein.
Zu, ähm...
Zu 1.700.
Selbst mit Inflation
ist das nicht zu erklären.
Aber das war damals echt high-end.
Und die gab es sogar passiv gekühlt.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Die konnten damals high-end Grafikkarten
passiv gekühlt erstellen.
Das war übrigens noch vor DVI
oder HDMI
oder Displayport.
VGA-Output.
Aber man konnte damals
richtig nice Half-Life 1
1.600 mal 1.200
auf einem Röhrenmonitor spielen.
Flüssig.
Ich meine wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht irgendwie mit
200 FPS
oder sonst was.
Aber flüssig.
Und es sah nice aus
für die Damen.
Nein, nein, nein.
1.600 mal 1.200.
X63P.
Hast du schon das Video von...
Moment, welches?
Ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich das schon gemacht.
Jetzt hätten die nur ein Video.
Weißt du, wie viel dein PC im Idle verbraucht?
Ja, weiß ich.
Aber nicht aus dem Kopf.
Wir haben das
gemessen im Stream.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was es war.
Chat, ihr seid doch so
schlau, high-IQ-mäßig
unterwegs. Kann sich jemand noch
dran erinnern?
Was der PC Idle verbraucht hat?
Ich weiß es beim besten Willen
nicht mehr.
Es war aber nicht viel.
Nee, als wir den zusammengebaut haben.
Es war nicht viel.
Nein, nein, nein.
Es war weit unter 100 Watt.
Es war nicht viel.
Die Dinger sind Idle...
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwie sowas, würde ich vielleicht sagen.
Die Dinger sind Idle recht sparsam.
Ja, ja, genau.
Es war ziemlich wenig.
Es war auch weniger, als ich gedacht habe.
Die Dinger sind tatsächlich relativ sparsam,
wenn sie Idle sind.
Aber wenn sie unter...
Last sind, verbrauchen die extrem viel.
Quatsch, 5 Watt war es nicht.
Nein, das war schon mehr.
Also,
Volllast hat das Ding...
Weiß ich.
Ich glaube,
550 Watt oder irgendwie sowas mal
gezogen.
Ja, guck mal. Damals konnte man
auf den Grafikkarten den Speicher
und so noch, ich vermute mal, dass das Speicher war,
hier noch erkennen.
Und ich war damals mega beeindruckt,
weil es gab damals ein...
Artikel in der Gamestar,
da stand, dass auf der Größe eines Pfennigstücks
in diesem Topmodell 50 Millionen Transistoren verbaut sind.
Leute, Größe von einem Pfennigstück und 50 Millionen Transistoren,
da lacht sich heute jede CPU kaputt.
Das ist...
Das ist so...
Das...
Das ist so groß, dass du es unter dem Mikroskop fast noch siehst.
So klein, dass du es fast noch siehst.
Heute sind...
Ist das so klein?
Ich weiß nicht, was du auf einer Fläche von so einem Daumennagel hast heute an Transistoren,
aber ich glaube, das sind deutlich mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel mehr,
aber es sind deutlich mehr.
Naja, zumindest das war meine erste Grafikkarte,
die ich mir selbst gekauft habe.
Ich weiß, ich habe jetzt komplett verdrängt,
was ich eigentlich raus...
Achso, ja, Preis, Preisentwicklung.
Ja, genau.
Und da haben sich die Preise halt krass entwickelt
und bei Smartphones auch.
Ich meine, wenn ich das mal vergleiche,
dann mit...
Beispielsweise, ich hatte ja früher so ein dickes...
So ein Nokia-Klopper.
Der hat...
Der hat auch nur...
Der hat auch nur ein Apple-O-Night gekostet,
versus ein aktuelles iPhone.
Wobei man das halt nicht...
Das...
Der Vergleich ist tatsächlich ein bisschen unfair.
So ein aktuelles Smartphone hat natürlich auch deutlich mehr Funktionen,
deutlich mehr Technik.
Und...
Und es ist ein ganz anderes Gerät.
Das kannst du nicht vergleichen.
Du kannst kein aktuelles Smartphone vergleichen
mit so einem fetten Nokia-Klopper.
Zusammen.
Oh, ein HM-PCR.
Okay.
Und da sieht man jetzt irgendwie...
Okay, das ist die Temperatur.
Und wo sieht man...
Habe ich nicht irgendwo ein Bild gehabt?
Von so einem Power-Meter?
Ich hatte doch da so ein Ding angeschlossen.
Oder vielleicht sage ich es einfach nur...
Oh, da habe ich...
Da habe ich ein bisschen gestruggelt,
das reinzukriegen.
Zumal ich...
Zumal ich keinen Platz hatte hier.
Ich habe hier oben drüben...
Ich habe hier drüben drüber das Ring-Light gehabt.
Und ich habe kaum was gesehen.
Das war ganz grausam.
Ach ja, Leute.
Und die Haarrisse im Mainboard,
die waren natürlich ganz kritisch.
Das war ja...
Ich habe das hier irgendwann einge...
Wobei, ich habe es noch gar nicht in...
Hier hatte ich es gar nicht ins Gehäuse gebaut.
Hier hatte ich es einfach nur angeschlossen.
Nee, hier hatte ich es einfach nur angeschlossen.
Ja, und da war die Grafikkarte auch noch gar nicht dran.
Als ich das ins Gehäuse eingebaut habe,
haben die Leute die ganze Zeit erzählt,
Max, wenn du die Grafikkarte so einbaust,
dann bekommst du Haarrisse im Mainboard.
Ja, also,
smartphone-technisch tut sich die letzten Jahre
tatsächlich recht wenig.
Das stimmt schon.
Discords new icon.
Oh, ein cute Discord-Icon.
Da haben wir drauf gewartet, oder?
Weil ich habe Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich weiß, ich habe die letzten Tage
ein bisschen wenig Stream-Sorge gemacht.
Aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Ich hatte beispielsweise gestern...
A broke star for one million potatoes.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gestern
den ganzen Tag Warnungsarbeiten
auf der Arbeit gemacht.
Wobei das relativ entspannte Warnungsarbeiten waren.
Ich musste legit
irgendwie drei Befehle ausführen
den ganzen Tag über.
Aber es war halt trotzdem immer wieder mal an PC gucken.
Geht es jetzt weiter? Nein? Okay.
Dann...
Wie funktioniert eine Wortsuche? Gibt es da eine KI für?
Ja!
Ja, ja. Naja, KI ist vielleicht ein bisschen
zu viel gesagt.
Aber ja, gibt es.
Zwar.
Worts.
Alle Worts.
Ja, Archiv durchsuchen. Du kannst hier beispielsweise nach Keckel suchen.
Guck. Und der hat so ein
Transkript von dem, was ich sage.
In der Volltext-Suche drin.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wie es genau funktioniert aktuell.
Wobei der Max hat es ja schon geschrieben.
Open
Open iWhisper.
Und dann in Volltext-Suche rein.
Also, initial
hatten wir in der Cloud
Grafikkarten-Server gemietet.
Also Server mit GPU.
Ich weiß nicht, Herr Max, weißt du noch, was wir da gemietet haben?
Für um initiale Index
beziehungsweise initiale
Transkript-Erstellung zu machen.
Ich glaube, wir hatten eine Kiste
gemietet mit 30
80. Mit zwei 3080
Grafikkarten drin oder sowas.
Oh, war das schon eine
4090?
Nee, oder? Wir haben das doch schon länger.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht.
Es lief zumindest
zwei Wochen.
Bis das
indiziert war. Oder halt
transkribiert war.
Weiß ich nicht.
Wie sieht das bei mir aus?
Habe ich noch meine Worts?
Oh nein!
Temp-E-Mail liegt.
Ich habe doch alles noch drin.
Ja, wenn die
TOS-Musik verwenden, dann kann das sein.
Aber dafür gibt es ja
mittlerweile die Möglichkeit, dass du im
Watt eine andere Musikspur nimmst
als im Stream.
Vielleicht sind die aber auch so faul wie ich und machen das nicht.
Managed MongoDB
Hosting Provider empfiehlt.
Nein, habe ich gar keine Erfahrung mit.
Muss es Managed MongoDB sein
oder willst du einfach nur eine gescheit funktionierende
NoSQL-Datenbank?
Weil da haben die ganzen Cloud-Anbieter ihre eigenen Dinger.
Aber so Managed MongoDB,
keine Ahnung. Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher,
ob
hat Google sowas zum Beispiel?
Gar nicht, ob die sowas haben.
Also, weiß ich nicht.
Kenne ich nicht.
Ich habe auch mit MongoDB so gut wie nichts
zu tun. Ach, guck mal, hier gibt es sogar
einen Screenshot von der Indexierung.
Also, PyTorch.
So, also das,
da hatten wir eine Kiste
mit
Wo sieht man das?
Sieht man da, was das für eine Grafik?
Ah, hier, hier, die Grafik.
Also, das war eine 3090 war es.
3090.
Die hat gekostet 36 Cent
pro Stunde.
Und wir hatten es eineinhalb Wochen laufen.
Oben links. Ah, hier.
Ah, hier.
Rtx3090.
Rx3090.
RunPod.
Da, irgendwas.
Da, wo es ging.
Das ist jetzt übrigens ein richtig gutes Beispiel,
warum sich
Cloud,
warum sich Cloud Infrastruktur
lohnen kann.
Überlegt euch mal.
Ihr habt jetzt die Auswahl, ihr stellt euch,
ihr kauft, also ihr habt
jetzt den Anwendungsfall,
also ein Beispiel,
ein Beispiel,
spiel dafür warum sich cloud infrastruktur richtig lohnen kann
stelle euch vor ihr habt der anwendungsfall ihr habt ganz viel
videomaterial und ihr wollt per ein ins transkript von erstellen also quasi
textform dessen was gesagt wurde in dem video und ihr kauft euch selbst eine
kiste mit 32 gb ram 16 cpu und 30 90 da seid ihr für eine ordentliche kiste
doch schon ein paar tausend euro los ich könnte jetzt allerdings auch
hergehen und euch sowas in der cloud mieten
dann bezahlt ihr 36 cent die stunde und je nachdem wie lange ihr braucht
naja und ihr bezahlt auch keine stromkosten die sind dabei je nachdem
wie lange ihr braucht lohnt sich das richtig preismäßig ja von mehreren
tausend euro zu ein paar hundert euro kann ausrechnen was das gekostet hat 36
cent die stunde sind am tag acht euro so acht euro mal wieder wieder hast du
gesagt max einheit worden war 14 14 tage 14 tage 120 euro so habe 120 euro
bezahlt wirst es paar tausend euro für eigene kiste hinstellen und zusammen
bauen und hinstellen kacke also da lohnt sich laut infrastruktur ich habe auch
noch einen anderen anwendungszweck und man richtig gesehen dass es wirklich
was bringt ich musste mal open street view maps
prozessen für routenplanung und dafür haben wir eine klub 48 32 kerne oder die
24 kerne 128 g ne 88 wasser 8 und 24 kerne 96 g vm haben wir damals bei
hetzner genommen und haben das prozessen lassen innerhalb von weiß nicht zwei
stunden dann habe ich am ende
drei euro 50 bezahlt oder so dass das ganz transkript in deutsch ohne probleme
funktioniert ja und da lohnt sich das halt mega für sowas wenn man solche
infrastruktur wirklich 24 7 laufen lassen will für monate und jahre dann
kann man sich überlegen das wird schon ganz schön teuer aber wenn man mal so
kurze börs power braucht da ist klar dass ein anwendungsgebiet zumindest wo
sich cloud infrastruktur richtig lohnt und auch ein anwendungsgebiet wo
cloud-infrastruktur deutlich deutlich billiger sein kann als eigene
hardware in vielen fällen ist cloud-infrastruktur nicht billiger als das
selbst zu machen oder generell cloud sachen in der cloud laufstelle nicht
unbedingt billiger also selbst zu machen aber da messe viel billiger okay ich gehe
zu essen wir sehen uns vielleicht noch mal gucken müssen ja noch mal ein
bisschen technik krams und zwar wieder anschauen ich riecht spock heute war man
denn heute
please please kein kein keck javascript heute kein keck javascript please das
halte ich heute aus und gucken alles klar wir sehen uns bis denn ich habe
hunger macht's gut